Hi, this is Joel Blackstock with the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast. And today I sat down with someone who I've been a longtime fan of and been reading since I was in high school, David Tacey. Tacey is kind of a public intellectual in Australia. He's a writer of many books. One of the first books that brought me to Jung called How to Read Jung and the Jung Reader. He's a professor at La Trobe University in Melbourne, and he's also a professor at the Australian Center for Christianity and
大家好，我是 Taproot Therapy Collective 播客的乔尔·布莱克斯托克（Joel Blackstock）。今天，我采访了一位我仰慕已久、从高中起就开始阅读其作品的嘉宾——大卫·泰西（David Tacey）。泰西在澳大利亚是一位颇具影响力的公共知识分子，著有多部作品。我接触荣格的第一本书就是他写的《如何阅读荣格》（How to Read Jung）和《荣格读本》（The Jung Reader）。他是墨尔本拉筹伯大学（La Trobe University）的教授，同时也是澳大利亚基督教与
Culture. To list all of his accomplishments would take a long, long time. But Tacey is a student of anthropology, religion, sociology, and the history of psychoanalytic therapy. So he goes back and knows a lot of the history of the profession and is a very interesting writer with a lot of very unique insights. The conversation covers a lot of Jung's early life and work and exactly what Carl Jung was. Also comparative religion, politics, and all the things in the middle. So I hope that you enjoy the interview,
文化中心的教授。要列举他所有的成就需要很长很长的时间。但泰西是人类学、宗教、社会学和精神分析治疗史的研究者。因此，他回溯并了解该领域的许多历史，是一位非常有见地、观点独特的作家。这次谈话涵盖了荣格的早年生活和工作，以及卡尔·荣格究竟是谁。此外还涉及比较宗教、政治以及介于两者之间的所有事物。所以我希望你们能喜欢这次采访，
and I'm going to go ahead and roll that now. That boy needs therapy. Lie down on the couch. Frontier Psychiatry. Well, I was interested in a lot of the one of the things that we talked about is just kind of because the podcast is for people
现在我就开始播放。那男孩需要治疗。躺在沙发上。前沿精神病学。嗯，我感兴趣的很多事情，我们谈论的一点是因为这个播客是为那些
who may not have a huge vested interest and they may not have a ton of knowledge about all these things. They probably have encountered Jung a little bit. One of the things we talked about is just that Jung is such a big topic. People kind of cherry pick different things in a way that doesn't make sense a lot of the time and i think american yungianism particularly is bad about just
可能没有太大既得利益，对所有这些事情也没有太多了解的人准备的。他们可能对荣格有一点了解。我们谈论的一点是，荣格是一个如此宏大的话题。人们往往会以一种在很多时候说不通的方式去挑选不同的东西，我认为美国荣格心理学尤其糟糕，因为它只是
sanitizing it where it's like it's almost like well it's religion plus supportive counseling that's what it means to be a yungian analyst or it's but you know they kind of discard the the process or the parts of it that are maybe threatening to them or harder to do something with. I mean, do you have anything to say about that? Well, Jung is a huge area. I mean, I've spent 50 years in the area and I don't feel I've even begun to really cover all bases. Jung is a kind of a universe of thought within himself.
将其净化，就好像是“宗教加支持性咨询”，这就是成为荣格分析师的意义，或者……你知道，他们抛弃了那些对他们来说可能具有威胁性或难以处理的过程或部分。我的意思是，你对此有什么看法吗？嗯，荣格是一个巨大的领域。我的意思是，我在这个领域花了50年，我觉得我甚至还没有真正涵盖所有基础。荣格本身就是一个思想宇宙。
And there are parts of the, there's still parts of the collective works I haven't even read. They're so dense, especially the last work he did on alchemy. You virtually need a much better knowledge of Latin than I have to work through those. As you know, Jung often dropped Latin, ancient Greek, Arabic, French, Italian terms and phrases,
而且《全集》中仍有一些部分我甚至还没读过。它们太深奥了，尤其是他最后关于炼金术的作品。你几乎需要比我好得多的拉丁语知识才能读懂那些。如你所知，荣格经常使用拉丁语、古希腊语、阿拉伯语、法语、意大利语的术语和短语，
and it's quite inhibiting. So that's why a London publisher asked me some years ago to write a book called How to Read Jung because there's really no way that people could just dive in unprepared. Perhaps the only way of diving in unprepared would be to read his memoirs, Memories, Dreams, Reflections. It's a very accessible book. And the other book that's accessible is Essays on Contemporary Events
这非常令人拘束。所以这就是为什么几年前一位伦敦出版商请我写一本名为《如何阅读荣格》的书，因为人们真的无法在毫无准备的情况下直接深入研究。也许唯一可以毫无准备地深入研究的方法就是阅读他的回忆录《回忆、梦、反思》。这是一本非常通俗易懂的书。另一本通俗易懂的书是《当代事件论文集》
and also, of course, Man and His Symbols. But the problem with Man and His Symbols, he's deliberately trying to reach a wide audience, and it's almost a kind of a kindergarten book. It's a publisher book, you know. I mean, he's responding to the publisher in london who wanted him to do an introduction and i think that was john freeman who who interviewed him on the bbc on a number of occasions um so that book is not terribly
当然还有《人及其象征》。但《人及其象征》的问题在于，他刻意试图触及广泛的受众，这几乎是一本幼儿园级别的书。这是一本出版商的书，你知道的。我的意思是，他在回应伦敦的出版商，对方希望他写一篇导言，我想那是约翰·弗里曼，他曾在BBC多次采访过他，所以那本书并不是特别
terrific i'd rather suggest people start with Memories, Dreams, Reflections if they want to dive in. In the collective works, well, even to buy them is a big financial investment. But the one to start with, I think, is Volume 7, Two Essays on Analytical Psychology, is a nice introduction to the field. When I was young, someone gave me Aion, or I-on as it's pronounced, A-I-O-N, and that was far too advanced for me.
好。如果人们想深入研究，我宁愿建议他们从《回忆、梦、反思》开始。至于《全集》，光是购买它们就是一笔巨大的经济投资。但我认为应该从第七卷《分析心理学论文集》开始，这是对该领域很好的介绍。我年轻时，有人给了我《艾昂》（Aion，发音为I-on），那对我来说太深奥了。
I think I was 19 or 20, and i couldn't make head or tail of it too many ancient languages and too many scientific terms so um just just getting your toe into the young field is quite a challenge for starting off it It's hard to understand what it is. I mean, a lot of your work and John Beebe's work with MBTI brought me into it because we're kind of in a cognitive behavioral therapy desert here. Depth psychology is just not something that you encounter the people. If you encounter it, it's just to write it off. Either like, okay, Jung invented the collective unconscious and did nothing. that was a little bullet point in the psychology 101 chapter moving on and um yeah i mean i think what gets people too is that there's a ton of phases over his life and i mean i have a hard time following him into
我想我当时19或20岁，我完全看不懂，里面有太多的古语言和太多的科学术语，所以，刚开始接触荣格领域确实是一个挑战。很难理解它到底是什么。我的意思是，你和约翰·比比关于MBTI的很多工作把我带入了这一领域，因为我们这里处于认知行为疗法的荒漠。深度心理学根本不是你会遇到的人们所谈论的东西。如果你遇到了，也只是被否定。要么就是，好吧，荣格发明了集体无意识，然后什么也没做。那只是心理学101章节里的一个小要点，然后就跳过了。而且，我认为让人们感到困惑的是，他一生中经历了太多的阶段，我很难跟随他进入
the alchemy stuff i just i mean i believe that early science probably was projective and he's right that people were projecting psychology onto you know pre scientific science it's just not super interesting to me personally um but there's these phases that he goes through as a person and i think a lot of different jungian scholars or analysts relate to different parts of those phases and they kind of try and make that all of it even though he changes quite a bit um and maybe doesn't know what he even thinks he's you know chewing on things as he's as he's uh growing i've just finished reading catafalque by peter kingsley um and that's a very fascinating book um another another writer from the uk and he he adopts the view which I have a lot of sympathy with,
炼金术那些东西。我的意思是，我相信早期的科学可能是投射性的，他是对的，人们把心理学投射到了前科学时代的科学上，这对我个人来说并不是特别有趣。但他作为一个人的确经历了这些阶段，我认为许多不同的荣格学者或分析师关注这些阶段的不同部分，他们试图把这一切融为一体，尽管他改变了很多，而且也许他自己都不知道自己在想什么，他在成长过程中不断地咀嚼着这些东西。我刚读完彼得·金斯利的《灵柩》（Catafalque），那是一本非常迷人的书，另一位来自英国的作家，他采取了一种我非常赞同的观点，
that most Jungians have got Jung completely wrong, that they've domesticated him. That would be my experience. Yeah, they've turned him into a pussycat, but actually he's a raging lion and a very dangerous and threatening thinker in the tradition of Friedrich Nietzsche or Schopenhauer or Schiller or any of his German forebears and of course one of the tendencies that America does when someone becomes popular. America tends to make them more simple than they are. They make them somehow more digestible and more domesticated.
即大多数荣格学者完全误解了荣格，他们驯化了他。这就是我的体会。是的，他们把他变成了一只温顺的小猫，但实际上他是一头咆哮的狮子，是一位像弗里德里希·尼采、叔本华、席勒或他任何德国先辈那样的危险且具有威胁性的思想家。当然，当某人变得流行时，美国有一种倾向，那就是倾向于把他们变得比实际更简单。他们使他们变得更容易消化，也更驯化。
And it's a strange habit that America has with popularizing people and often getting them wrong in the process. But Jung, according to Peter Kingsley, Jung is a full-blown mystic and a religious prophet and that the Jungians don't want to admit this because they are invested with the idea of him being a scientist. And, in fact, when I met the Jung family in Switzerland some years ago to ask for permission to write a book which I've published called The Jung Reader, which has come out in several languages now, that book was designed to replace Joseph Campbell's book, The Portable Jung, which was
这是一种奇怪的习惯，美国在普及人物时往往会把他们搞错。但根据彼得·金斯利的说法，荣格是一位彻头彻尾的神秘主义者和宗教先知，而荣格学者们不想承认这一点，因为他们执着于他是一位科学家的想法。事实上，几年前我在瑞士见到荣格家族时，请求他们允许我写一本名为《荣格读本》的书，该书现在已经以多种语言出版，那本书的设计初衷是为了取代约瑟夫·坎贝尔的《便携式荣格》，那本书是
edited by Joseph Campbell in 1972, which is a long time ago. And there's been a massive amount in the Jung field written since 1972, changed our views of Jung almost completely. So I wrote that and I met the family in their house in Zurich and they still have this impression that Jung is a scientist. I mean, I found it really hard to understand. I mean, he's a philosopher, first and foremost. He's a philosopher who works in the field of psychology. That's how I would define him. And his philosophy is, of course, extremely dependent on theology as well and on ancient medieval studies and classical studies. He's a kind of Renaissance man, a Renaissance thinker, and he seems to be fully grasped,
由约瑟夫·坎贝尔在1972年编辑的，那已经是很久以前的事了。自1972年以来，荣格领域已经有了大量的著作，几乎完全改变了我们对荣格的看法。所以我写了那本书，并在苏黎世的家中见到了他的家人，他们仍然认为荣格是一位科学家。我的意思是，我发现这真的很难理解。我的意思是，他首先是一位哲学家。他是一位在心理学领域工作的哲学家。这就是我定义他的方式。当然，他的哲学也极大地依赖于神学、古代中世纪研究和古典研究。他是一个文艺复兴式的人，一个文艺复兴式的思想家，他似乎完全掌握了
have full grasp of several disciplines, including biology, anthropology, archaeology, physics of course he worked with the Nobel Prize winning physicist Wolfgang Pauli and before that he worked of course with Einstein in in Zurich they were in the same Institute together the Polytechnic, and they befriended each other. And it was Einstein who suggested to Jung that he might explore the field of synchronicity. That came from Einstein. And they both liked red wine, and they would go to Jung's holiday house at Bollingen on the lake called the Bollingen Tower. And apparently they had rip-roaring times down there. But unfortunately there's no record of the conversations
多门学科，包括生物学、人类学、考古学、物理学。当然，他曾与诺贝尔奖得主物理学家沃尔夫冈·泡利合作，在此之前，他当然还在苏黎世与爱因斯坦共事，他们在同一个研究所——理工学院，他们成为了朋友。正是爱因斯坦建议荣格去探索共时性领域。这来自爱因斯坦。他们都喜欢红酒，他们会去荣格在湖边的度假屋，也就是博林根塔。显然，他们在那里度过了非常愉快的时光。但不幸的是，没有关于这些谈话的记录
between Einstein and Jung. And I think that would be be mention what kind of gold mine that would be today to release this type of information well i think there was a just voracious hunger for him to create a kind of lens to few human experience that was a unified principle the unified theory of everything you know there was no discipline left out because like the the difference in jung and i i think what a lot of other people who are doing objective sciences is that his psychology is purely phenomenological i mean it is what he is feeling on the inside he's not really worried about what is on the outside as much as what is
在爱因斯坦和荣格之间。我想如果能提到那将是多么大的金矿啊，如果今天能发布这类信息的话。嗯，我认为人们有一种极其强烈的渴望，想要创造一种观察人类经验的视角，那是一个统一的原则，一个万物理论。你知道，没有任何学科被遗漏，因为荣格与其他从事客观科学的人的区别在于，他的心理学纯粹是现象学的。我的意思是，这是他内心感受到的东西，他并不太担心外在的东西，而更关心
the experience of this like and i think in my i mean and you know more about this than i do but like what i feel when you read his career is that he tries to be a scientist until he can't be anymore and then he and then and he's worried about the perception he's worried about this and then he gets to a point where it's like you know i can't do this scientifically. It has to be this direct experience, descent into whatever. That is beautifully said. It kind of looks crazy to people. May I quote you on that? That is a great quotable quote.
这种体验是什么。而且我认为，在我的……我的意思是，你比我更了解这一点，但当你阅读他的职业生涯时，我觉得他试图成为一名科学家，直到他无法再做到为止，然后他担心人们的看法，他担心这个，然后他到了一个地步，就像是，你知道，我不能科学地做到这一点。它必须是这种直接的体验，深入到任何东西中去。说得太好了。这在人们看来有点疯狂。我可以引用你的话吗？那是一句非常值得引用的名言。
He tries to be a scientist until he can't do it anymore. That is so good, Joel. And there's probably some of that inner voice where Freud is pushing him for a long time to be a scientist get this weird new age stuff out of there so that people will respect you know this profession because don't forget that freud got rid of jung in 1913 because he felt that jung was could be seen as a prophet or a mystic or a spiritual leader and but did jung get rid of Freud? He's maybe still having a fight with someone who is not there for a while. He was having a fight with someone who
他试图成为一名科学家，直到他无法再做到为止。这太棒了，乔尔。可能内心深处有某种声音，弗洛伊德长期以来一直在推动他成为一名科学家，把那些奇怪的新时代的东西赶走，这样人们才会尊重这个职业。因为别忘了，弗洛伊德在1913年解雇了荣格，因为他觉得荣格可能被视为先知、神秘主义者或精神领袖。但荣格解雇了弗洛伊德吗？他可能还在和一个不在场的人争吵了一段时间。他一直在和一个
wasn't fighting back all his life. I mean, you can read the last pieces that Jung ever wrote in like Memory Streams, Reflections, Man and His Symbols. Jung is still fighting Freud, although Freud died 40 years earlier. But absolutely right about that. When they met, it must have been absolutely electric, the atmosphere. I think the first time they met, they talked nonstop for nine or ten hours straight. You know, they had a lot in common, but unfortunately, they had more not in common than they did have in common.
不还手的人争吵了一辈子。我的意思是，你可以读荣格写的最后几篇文章，比如《回忆、梦、反思》、《人及其象征》。荣格仍然在与弗洛伊德争吵，尽管弗洛伊德早在40年前就去世了。但关于这一点你是绝对正确的。当他们见面时，气氛一定非常紧张。我想他们第一次见面时，连续不停地谈了九到十个小时。你知道，他们有很多共同点，但不幸的是，他们不共同的地方比共同的地方更多。
But both of them were committed to the unconscious, which, by the way, Freud called it the subconscious. And Jung said, no, we can't call it the subconscious. That's too demeaning. Let's just call it the unconscious. So Freud took Jung's advice and Freud stopped after he met Jung. He stopped using the word subconscious. But Jung also offered Freud the word complex.
但他们都致力于研究无意识，顺便说一句，弗洛伊德称之为潜意识。而荣格说，不，我们不能称之为潜意识。那太贬低了。我们还是叫它无意识吧。所以弗洛伊德采纳了荣格的建议，在见到荣格后就停止使用潜意识这个词了。但荣格也向弗洛伊德提供了“情结”这个词。
That was Jung's own making which came out of his word association tests. He started to realise that people had complexes. When they were asked certain words and there was a long pause, Jung figured the reason there was a long pause was because people uh were confused on that particular something it triggered something in them so jung called it a complex and freud took that up and um when he split with freud that's when he invented his theory of psychological psychological types, which, of course, is now a huge industry in its own right. Every workplace in the world uses the Myers-Briggs type. They change it just enough to patent it and call it something else.
那是荣格自己的创造，源于他的词语联想测试。他开始意识到人们有情结。当被问到某些词时，会出现长时间的停顿，荣格认为长时间停顿的原因是人们对那个特定的东西感到困惑，它触发了他们内心的某些东西，所以荣格称之为情结，弗洛伊德采纳了这个词。当他与弗洛伊德决裂时，他发明了他的心理类型理论，这当然现在本身就是一个巨大的产业。世界上每个工作场所都在使用迈尔斯-布里格斯类型指标。他们只是稍微修改了一下以申请专利，然后换了个名字。
Yeah. And, in fact, sometimes these people ask me to speak about this background to psychological types, you know, introversion, extroversion. Jung uses those terms, and every time we talk about introverts and extroverts, we're quoting Jung without knowing it. Yeah. And that's why Jung invented that, because he could see that Freud was a different type to himself
是的。事实上，有时这些人会请我谈谈心理类型的背景，你知道，内向、外向。荣格使用了这些术语，每次我们谈论内向者和外向者时，我们都在不知不觉中引用荣格。是的。这就是荣格发明它的原因，因为他能看出弗洛伊德与他自己是不同的类型
and that part of the reason of their falling out wasn't just personal difficulties or faults but they were looking at the world through different lenses and Adler too I think he saw Freud Adler and him so passionately and going in very different directions adler probably had more in common than you than freud did the compensation and tension of opposites is a lot like yes the power struggle power was very important to adler as well and the idea that for every external part that's big there is an internal part that is big that is unseen you know they're both noticing that probably because they're sitting with Freud, who has a lot that he never deals with. But the problem is that Freud wasn't at all grateful.
他们决裂的部分原因不仅仅是个人困难或缺点，而是他们通过不同的视角看待世界。阿德勒也是，我想他非常热情地看待弗洛伊德、阿德勒和他自己，并朝着非常不同的方向发展。阿德勒可能与荣格的共同点比与弗洛伊德的更多。补偿和对立面的张力非常相似，是的。权力斗争对阿德勒来说也很重要，而且对于每一个巨大的外部部分，都有一个巨大的、看不见的内部部分，这种想法，你知道，他们都注意到了这一点，可能是因为他们坐在弗洛伊德身边，他有很多从未处理过的问题。但问题是，弗洛伊德一点也不感激。
I mean, Jung spent several years of his life constructing this theory of psychological types, almost as an apology to Freud as to explain why they split. But Freud never received the gift in the right spirit. He just ignored Nul from then on. And of course, it was a very Adlerian-like power struggle between Freud and Jung. But Freud had coordinated this so-called special committee that sat in London under the leadership of Ernest Jones to try and test the scientific credibility of Jung's ideas. Naturally, Ernest Jones, who was a close associate of Freud, came up with a view that Jung's scientific ideas weren't really empirically valid, and that Jung had gone off into philosophizing. Well, it's an intuitive and felt psychology, you know, it's not one that you can measure and turn into a number, like behaviorism or cognitive therapy to a third.
我的意思是，荣格花了几年的时间构建了这个心理类型理论，几乎是作为对弗洛伊德的一种道歉，以解释他们为什么决裂。但弗洛伊德从未以正确的态度接受这份礼物。从那以后，他只是无视荣格。当然，弗洛伊德和荣格之间存在着一种非常阿德勒式的权力斗争。但弗洛伊德协调了一个所谓的特别委员会，在欧内斯特·琼斯的领导下在伦敦开会，试图测试荣格思想的科学可信度。自然地，作为弗洛伊德亲密伙伴的欧内斯特·琼斯得出的结论是，荣格的科学思想在经验上并不真正有效，荣格已经陷入了哲学化。嗯，这是一种直觉和感性的心理学，你知道，它不是那种你可以测量并变成数字的东西，不像行为主义或认知疗法那样。
Yeah. But that London group was so savage toward Jung. I actually feel that he never really recovered his reputation. That was so influential, especially in Europe and parts of America as well, that in Canada, that Jung was sort of completely knocked out of business and he had to rely on his close associates, most of whom, by the way, were Jewish. And yet, you know, Freud kept claiming that Jung was anti-Semitic.
是的。但那个伦敦小组对荣格非常残忍。我实际上觉得他从未真正恢复过他的声誉。这太有影响力了，特别是在欧洲和美国的部分地区，在加拿大也是如此，以至于荣格在某种程度上完全被排挤出了业务，他不得不依靠他的亲密伙伴，顺便说一句，他们中的大多数是犹太人。然而，你知道，弗洛伊德一直声称荣格是反犹太主义者。
And so Freud played the race card on Jung. And I've written about this extensively. And I thought it was very unfortunate because, of course, this was during the Nazi era. And so Freud was very careful to try and pin anti-Semitism on Jung during the Nazi era, which basically meant that Jung's reputation was sunk. One thing that fascinates me, Joel, is that Jung's relationship to the Nazis was on the whole a very negative one. Like, you know, he wrote essays called Wotan, which was about the madness of Hitler. Whereas someone like Martin Heidegger, the philosopher, probably the most philosopher of the 20th century, was a full-blown member of the Nazi party.
所以弗洛伊德在荣格身上打了种族牌。我对此进行了广泛的论述。我认为这非常不幸，因为当然，这是在纳粹时代。所以弗洛伊德非常小心地试图在纳粹时代将反犹太主义归咎于荣格，这基本上意味着荣格的声誉彻底毁了。有一件事让我很着迷，乔尔，那就是荣格与纳粹的关系总体上是非常负面的。比如，你知道，他写了名为《沃坦》的文章，是关于希特勒的疯狂的。而像马丁·海德格尔这样的哲学家，可能是20世纪最伟大的哲学家，却是纳粹党的正式成员。
And somehow or other, he has- He's rehabilitated pretty fast for some reason. How did that happen? You know, I mean- Or the scientist happen you know i mean or the scientist you know the rock you look at von braun and a lot of these people who had to know about the supply chain and things that we wait and forgive them because they're useful yeah so heidegger was forgiven i mean admittedly it took a while he Heidegger was only forgiven quite relatively recently, during the 1980s, late 70s,
不知何故，他……他很快就得到了平反，出于某种原因。这是怎么发生的？你知道，我的意思是……或者科学家，你知道，你看冯·布劳恩和许多这些人，他们必须了解供应链和我们等待的事情，我们原谅他们，因为他们有用。是的，所以海德格尔被原谅了。我的意思是，诚然，这花了一段时间，海德格尔直到最近才被原谅，在20世纪80年代，70年代末，
but Jung has still got the stain of anti-Semitism. There's some hit pieces. I mean, I think one of the things that, it may be part of the reason the Red Book got published, but Richard Knoll has these books where he attacks young and says all this stuff that i really just don't think is true at all you know he says he was trying to start a cult and it was like he didn't want an institute he the only reason he did it was he was like they're going to do this with or without me so i might as well be a little bit
但荣格仍然背负着反犹太主义的污点。有一些攻击性的文章。我的意思是，我认为其中一件事，这可能是《红书》出版的部分原因，但理查德·诺尔有这些书，他攻击荣格并说所有这些我真的认为根本不是事实的事情。你知道，他说他试图建立一个邪教，就像他根本不想要一个研究所一样，他这样做的唯一原因是他说他们无论如何都会这样做，所以我最好还是稍微
involved in it um you know he asked not to be lionized after he died you know there's if he was trying to be kind of a mad prophet or start a cult he did a bad job of it um but one of the things with noel because i i actually read richard noel's stuff before i read uh young before i knew a lot about young and so i was willing to kind of accept the theory and then it was slowly like what because you know he he says you know that a big tenet of unionism not richard noel doesn't say this but like a big part of jung's psychology is that religion is projective you know we we take something internal and then we need the world to function a certain way and then we start to believe certain things through mythology or ritual or and and that process is how you can understand what's going on on the inside
参与其中。你知道，他要求在他死后不要被神化。你知道，如果他试图成为某种疯狂的先知或建立一个邪教，他做得非常糟糕。但关于诺尔的一件事，因为我实际上在读荣格之前，在我了解荣格之前，就读过理查德·诺尔的东西，所以我愿意接受这种理论，然后慢慢地就像是，什么？因为你知道，他说，你知道，荣格主义的一个大原则——理查德·诺尔不这么说，但荣格心理学的一个重要部分是宗教是投射性的。你知道，我们把内在的东西拿出来，然后我们需要世界以某种方式运作，然后我们开始通过神话或仪式相信某些事情，那个过程就是你如何理解内心正在发生的事情
and the deepest part of the unconscious and so as you're reading the book, and Noel essentially is like, well, yeah, you know, the biggest organizing principle of our entire civilization and society since the Bronze Age, it doesn't correspond to psychology at all. It's just created randomly in a vacuum, totally removed from the psychology of the people making it. It's like, wait, what? I mean, I don't, is he Catholic or something? I mean, I guess if you're saying that the word of God is handed down in this book, then you need to separate
以及无意识中最深的部分。所以当你读这本书时，诺尔本质上就像是，好吧，是的，你知道，自青铜时代以来我们整个文明和社会最大的组织原则，它根本不对应心理学。它只是在真空中随机产生的，完全脱离了创造它的人的心理。就像，等等，什么？我的意思是，我不，他是天主教徒还是什么的？我的意思是，我想如果你说上帝的话语是在这本书中传下来的，那么你需要把它与心理学分开
that from psychology. But with any kind of healthy perspective on religion, how can you say that none of that corresponds to a psychological state? Our psychology is not part of our religion. I mean, we're picking these things at random to build civilizations around. That's wild.
但以任何健康的宗教视角来看，你怎么能说这些都不对应心理状态呢？我们的心理学不是我们宗教的一部分。我的意思是，我们随机挑选这些东西来围绕它们建立文明。这太疯狂了。
Well, I think Richard Knoll started with very malicious intent. You know, he had obviously read some Jung, but I don't think he read him correctly. And I think that Richard Knoll had deliberately misread Jung. See, one of the big things that separates psychology and religion is the symbolic attitude. So in depth psychology, pretty much everything is read through the lens of symbolism. But Richard Knoll is persistent in his tendency to read what jung says literally
嗯，我认为理查德·诺尔一开始就怀有非常恶意的意图。你知道，他显然读过一些荣格的作品，但我认为他读得不对。而且我认为理查德·诺尔故意误读了荣格。你看，区分心理学和宗教的一大因素是象征态度。所以在深度心理学中，几乎所有东西都是通过象征主义的视角来解读的。但理查德·诺尔坚持他倾向于字面地解读荣格所说的话
you know and to read it literally is to make it almost bizarre and um religion is not literal it's not a literal thing you know i was raised to episcopalian and it's there's a certain point that some people get to where they're like, OK, that's an allegory. That's an allegory. That's an allegory. But from here on out, it's literal. You know, the first book, there's a snake that is talking about eating fruit. Most people, you know, maybe not everyone, but most people who are Christian in America are probably like, well, you know, that's that's a myth. It's an allegory for something. But then you get a little further in the Bible and they're like no but that part you can't and then some people are willing to make the whole thing a metaphor um but it's you know how much your religion is in control of your life or or where
你知道，字面地解读它几乎使它变得怪异。而且宗教不是字面的，它不是一个字面的东西。你知道，我是作为圣公会教徒长大的，有些人到了某个点，他们会说，好吧，那是一个寓言。那是一个寓言。那是一个寓言。但从这里开始，它是字面的。你知道，第一本书，有一条蛇在谈论吃水果。大多数人，你知道，也许不是每个人，但大多数在美国的基督徒可能觉得，嗯，你知道，那是一个神话。它是某种东西的寓言。但当你再往圣经后面读一点，他们就会说不，但那部分你不能。然后有些人愿意把整件事都当作隐喻。但你知道，你的宗教在多大程度上控制了你的生活，或者
you stop being a scientist and start being a person of faith where do you stop that i've written a whole book on this topic so i could talk for this for an hour. Those books tend to not sell a whole lot in the US. I don't know how they do in Australia. You can write books of religion and sell them, but you can't write books about religion and sell them. One of my books recently is called Religion as Metaphor. And it's all about this question and it it it says that there is um a tendency for christian for christians to read the old testament metaphorically you know that the the the eden garden of eden creation myth a lot of christians are happy to read that as a myth one of my students said to me come on she said you can't take a book that starts with a talking snake literally i think people do um i mean i've heard defenses of the snake
你在哪里停止成为一名科学家，开始成为一名有信仰的人？你在哪里停止？我写了一整本关于这个主题的书，所以我可以谈论这个一个小时。这些书在美国往往卖得不太好。我不知道它们在澳大利亚卖得怎么样。你可以写宗教书籍并卖掉它们，但你不能写关于宗教的书并卖掉它们。我最近的一本书叫《作为隐喻的宗教》。它全是关于这个问题的，它说有一种倾向，基督徒倾向于隐喻性地阅读旧约。你知道，伊甸园的创造神话，很多基督徒很乐意把它读作一个神话。我的一个学生对我说，得了吧，她说你不能字面地理解一本以会说话的蛇开头的书。我想人们会这样做。我的意思是，我听过对蛇的辩护
but i imagine there are many people in the deep south and the midwest of america who still read the bible literally that's the feeling i get I used to live in the States some years ago. Texas. You used to live in Texas too. Yeah. And a lot of people in Texas are reading, still reading the Bible literally. They've not caught on to the modern interpretation
但我认为在美国南部腹地和中西部，有许多人仍然字面地阅读圣经。这就是我的感觉。我几年前住在美国。德克萨斯州。你也住过德克萨斯州。是的。德克萨斯州的很多人都在阅读，仍然在字面地阅读圣经。他们还没有领会现代的解释
about reading it through symbol, myth, and metaphor. In fact, I did think about calling my book Religion as Myth, but my U.S. publisher advised me against that because in America, like in most countries, the word myth means falsehood, you know, like it has no merit. It's just untruth. And I didn't want that because I have a very strong respect for religion, but I also have a strong respect for the intellectual reading of religion.
关于通过象征、神话和隐喻来阅读它。事实上，我确实考虑过把我的书命名为《作为神话的宗教》，但我的美国出版商建议我不要这样做，因为在美国，像大多数国家一样，神话这个词意味着虚假，你知道，就像它没有任何价值一样。它只是不真实。我不想那样，因为我对宗教有非常强烈的尊重，但我也对宗教的理智解读有强烈的尊重。
And it was Jung who pointed out to me, one of the first people, that there's been a mistake made a long while ago of reading the Bible literally, and Jung couldn't abide the virgin birth of Jesus, for instance, nor could he abide the physical resurrection. But he saw both of these events, very important spiritual ideas that we need to contemplate. And he let patients continue their religious traditions. A couple of places he points people back to their religious tradition.
正是荣格最早向我指出，很久以前人们在解读《圣经》时犯了一个错误，那就是字面解读。例如，荣格无法接受耶稣的童贞降生，也无法接受肉身复活。但他认为这两个事件都是非常重要的精神理念，值得我们深思。他让病人继续保持他们的宗教传统。在某些情况下，他会引导人们回归他们的宗教传统。
He tells them to go back to the, there's the Muslim man and the Christians. So, I mean, he had respect and viewed the utility of this as something that enriched life and was helpful. Yes, he told them to go back, but he didn't tell them to go back to the literal reading of it all. So, you know, like if you were a Christian and you lapsed out because you couldn't read it literally, Jung would support you in that lapsing out and saying, look, but go back and read it non-literally and it would still be more important for you than read literally.
他告诉他们回归，比如那位穆斯林男子和基督徒。我的意思是，他尊重并看到了这些传统的实用价值，认为它们能丰富生活并有所助益。是的，他告诉他们回归，但他并没有让他们回归到对一切进行字面解读的状态。所以，如果你是一名基督徒，因为无法进行字面解读而放弃了信仰，荣格会支持你这种放弃，并说，去吧，但要以非字面的方式去阅读，这对你来说仍然比字面解读更有意义。
So, you know, that's a big topic of its own, but I don't want to waste our time talking only about religion. But as you know, Jung wrote whole books and volumes on religion, psychology of religion, East and West. American Jungians will tell you that Jung is their religion, which is a strange way to use Jung. I mean, it's a lens to understand what it is, but I don't think being a Jungian analyst is a religion
这是一个很大的话题，但我不想浪费时间只谈论宗教。但如你所知，荣格写过整整几卷关于宗教、宗教心理学、东方和西方的书。美国的荣格派学者会告诉你，荣格就是他们的宗教，这是一种奇怪的用法。我的意思是，这是一种理解事物的视角，但我并不认为成为一名荣格分析师是一种宗教。
in the way that some people will say. No. No, in fact, Jung was deadly opposed to this idea. It's funny, the people who loved Jung and the people who hated Jung had the same view about him, which was that he was starting a new religion. That's why people hated and loved him. But both were wrong because he kept saying, no, no, no, no, this is not what I'm doing.
不像有些人说的那样。不，事实上，荣格坚决反对这种观点。有趣的是，爱荣格的人和恨荣格的人对他的看法是一样的，都认为他在创立一种新宗教。这就是人们恨他或爱他的原因。但他们都错了，因为他一直说，不，不，不，这不是我在做的事情。
I'm building a psychological bridge to religion. He uses that metaphor, Joel, constantly. When he has the falling out with the priest, right? He was kind of trying to update Christianity. Yeah, yeah. The priest in Britain called Father Victor White. He followed Jung until he published Answer to Job, 1952. He writes a letter to Martin Buber too, where they disagree on religion.
我正在搭建一座通往宗教的心理学桥梁。乔尔，他一直使用这个比喻。当他与那位牧师闹翻时，对吧？他当时是在试图更新基督教。是的，是的。英国的那位牧师叫维克多·怀特神父。他一直追随荣格，直到荣格出版了1952年的《答约伯》。他还给马丁·布伯写过信，他们在宗教问题上存在分歧。
And there was a big falling out with Martin Buber in the Jewish tradition. Did the Pope ever respond? I knew that he wrote a letter to the Pope being like, oh, you're making Catholicism better, good job, this is what it's supposed to be like, and the Pope's like, of course, catholicism right i'm the pope um well that was pope pius the 12th and respond to him or anything who respond to who did the pope write jung back when jung wrote that letter no no he didn't no in fact from that point on Jung got banned by the Vatican. Don't tell the Pope he's doing a good job.
他和马丁·布伯在犹太传统问题上闹得很僵。教皇回应过吗？我知道他给教皇写过一封信，大意是说，哦，你正在让天主教变得更好，干得好，这才是它应该有的样子，而教皇的反应是，当然，天主教嘛，我就是教皇。嗯，那是教皇庇护十二世，他回应了吗？谁回应了谁？当荣格写那封信时，教皇回信了吗？没有，他没有。事实上，从那时起，荣格就被梵蒂冈禁了。别告诉教皇他做得很好。
The Vatican is very ambivalent about Jung because one thing that Jung did was, as you said, he returned certain Catholics to Catholicism where they'd abandoned it because they'd become enlightened or intellectually got sick of it. And the Pope actually sent Jung a blessing in, I think 1950 it wasn't the pope who delivered it personally but he passed it on to the catholic archbishop of zurich whose name i can't remember and jung got the blessing from the pope through the archbishop of zurich um i hope they realize that Jung was never even a Catholic. You know, like why he's getting blessed by the Pope was a bit of a strange. Well, they've banned Jung pretty much every decade since he died. It's like too many vocal clergy with podcasts and quills will start to write books about Jung
梵蒂冈对荣格的态度非常矛盾，因为荣格所做的一件事正如你所说，他让一些放弃了天主教的信徒回归了，因为他们变得开明了，或者在智力上对它感到厌倦了。教皇实际上在1950年左右送给荣格一个祝福，我想不是教皇亲自送达的，而是转交给了苏黎世的天主教大主教，我不记得他的名字了，荣格通过苏黎世大主教得到了教皇的祝福。我希望他们意识到荣格甚至从来都不是天主教徒。你知道，他为什么会得到教皇的祝福，这有点奇怪。嗯，自从他去世后，他们几乎每十年就禁一次荣格。就像太多有播客和笔杆子的神职人员开始写关于荣格的书一样。
and then they will come in and say, oh, no, you can't do that. That's right. I mean, there's a huge number of Catholic priests in the world, especially in North America, who have taken Jung very seriously and written books about him. And I think the Vatican has felt very insecure about this. And as you say, about every decade, they come out with a new edict, the Gatesjong.
然后他们就会介入说，哦，不，你不能那样做。没错。我的意思是，世界上有大量的天主教神父，特别是在北美，他们非常认真地对待荣格，并写了关于他的书。我认为梵蒂冈对此感到非常不安。正如你所说，大约每十年，他们就会发布一项新的法令，即“禁荣格令”。
It's hilarious, actually, because one of these things, anyone listening can Google it. It's called Jesus Christ, the Water of Life. It's online, and it's about 30 pages condemning Jung as a heretic, as a Gnostic, as a blasphemer. It's incredible, considered that the same church blessed him not too long ago. The Catholic Church does that to a lot of people. You know, Meister Eckhart is excommunicated and, you know, sainted.
这其实很滑稽，因为其中一件事，任何听众都可以去谷歌搜索。它叫《耶稣基督，生命之水》。它在网上，大约有30页，谴责荣格是异端、诺斯替教徒、亵渎者。这太不可思议了，考虑到同一个教会不久前还祝福过他。天主教会对很多人都这样做。你知道，埃克哈特大师被逐出教会，后来又被封为圣人。
In fact, Meister Eckhart, historians are now claiming, was murdered by the Vatican army on his way to Rome. He'd left Paris. He'd been called up by the Vatican. But because Eckhart had said that God has to be reborn in the human heart, and that was dangerous for the Catholic Church because there was only one person that was that close to God, and that was his son, Jesus Christ.
事实上，历史学家现在声称，埃克哈特大师在去罗马的路上被梵蒂冈军队谋杀了。他离开了巴黎。他被梵蒂冈传唤了。但因为埃克哈特曾说上帝必须在人类心中重生，这对天主教会来说很危险，因为只有一个人能那么接近上帝，那就是他的儿子，耶稣基督。
And so Eckhart, like all mystics, basically says the whole religious drama is about every person. It's not just about one person. And there's another person I should mention in this context, the German theologian, Eugene Dreverman, D-R-E-W-E-R-M-A-N, Eugene Dreverman, Eugene Dreverman, who's been banished by the Catholic Church. He's written 40 books on Catholicism and Jung,
所以埃克哈特，像所有的神秘主义者一样，基本上说整个宗教戏剧是关于每个人的。它不仅仅是关于一个人的。在这个背景下，我还应该提到另一个人，德国神学家尤金·德雷弗曼，D-R-E-W-E-R-M-A-N，尤金·德雷弗曼，他被天主教会驱逐了。他写了40本关于天主教和荣格的书，
but only three of them have been translated into English. I've read them all, and they're just absolutely stunning and I wish that somebody would translate the rest of these 40 books but the Catholic Church was up in arms and he got defrocked and he can't practice as a Catholic priest anymore. That's how serious they take the challenge from Jung. So religions are very aware of Jung, but mostly it's this hysterically negative point of view. One of the things that they all have in common is misreading Jung. If I can just give you a quick example, when Jung,, Jung was hugely influenced by Meister Eckhart, the late medieval mystic in the Rhineland, what we call Germany today.
但只有三本被翻译成英文。我全都读过，它们简直令人惊叹，我希望有人能翻译剩下的那40本书，但天主教会对此非常愤怒，他被剥夺了神职，不能再以天主教神父的身份执事了。这就是他们对待荣格挑战的严肃程度。所以宗教界非常了解荣格，但大多是这种歇斯底里的负面观点。他们共同的一点是误读了荣格。如果我能给你举个简单的例子，荣格深受莱茵兰（我们今天称之为德国的地方）中世纪晚期神秘主义者埃克哈特大师的影响。
And Jung believes that Eckhart is right about the idea that God needs to be reborn in the human soul. And so that made the authorities in Rome very negative toward Jung. But when Jung uses the word self, this is where a lot of the complication arises. He's actually borrowing the Indian idea of himself, capital S. The Atman. The Atman, yeah. And in Vatican and everywhere else, I've been reading this self as the ego. And so in this long 30-page diatribe against Jung,
荣格认为埃克哈特关于上帝需要在人类灵魂中重生的观点是正确的。这使得罗马的权威机构对荣格非常反感。但当荣格使用“自性”（Self）这个词时，很多复杂的问题就出现了。他实际上借用了印度的“自性”概念，大写的S，即“阿特曼”（Atman）。阿特曼，是的。而在梵蒂冈和其他地方，他们把这个“自性”解读为“自我”（ego）。所以在那篇长达30页针对荣格的抨击文章中，
they refer to Jung as narcissistic, egotistic, and making some kind of demonic religion out of the ego. Because the idea that we've got something in us that's an addition to the ego is not a Western idea. And it's threatening to the ego. To the hierarchies of that. It's threatening to the ego. But the idea of God being reborn in this capitalist self is, of course, standard in the East.
他们称荣格是自恋的、利己的，并用“自我”制造了一种恶魔般的宗教。因为我们内心拥有某种超越“自我”的东西，这并不是西方的观念。这对“自我”构成了威胁。对那种等级制度构成了威胁。这对“自我”构成了威胁。但上帝在“大写的自性”中重生的观念，当然在东方是标准的。
Hinduism. Buddhism has that, of course, but a slightly different direction because Buddhism doesn't believe in the self and it doesn't believe in God either. Well, if there's not a self you know what is being reincarnated or if there's not there's a lot of or what if there's not a self then how did the bodhisattvas have a self to come now different branches of buddhism sort of become hinduism or jainism again yeah they reintroduced the idea while claiming to not have it so what
印度教。佛教当然也有，但方向略有不同，因为佛教不相信“自性”，也不相信上帝。嗯，如果没有“自性”，你知道什么是轮回吗？或者如果没有“自性”，那么菩萨怎么会有“自性”来现身呢？佛教的不同分支又变回了印度教或耆那教。是的，他们在声称没有这种观念的同时又重新引入了它。所以，
in sense what jung is is the east in the the West. And he had such a hard time. He basically had Eastern insights, Eastern intuitions, but in the context of Western science. And Sonu Shamdasani, who's probably the leading scholar on Jung today, he lives in London, works at the University of London, was basically saying that the scientists disregarded Jung for being too religious, and the theologians disregarded Jung for being too mystical.
从某种意义上说，荣格就是西方的东方。他经历了很多困难。他基本上拥有东方的洞见和直觉，但却是在西方科学的语境下。索努·沙姆达萨尼（Sonu Shamdasani），可能是当今研究荣格的领军学者，他住在伦敦，在伦敦大学工作，他基本上说，科学家因为荣格太宗教化而忽视他，神学家因为荣格太神秘化而忽视他。
I have people who call me and they're like, well, I want to come see you, and they schedule. And then they're like, well, I looked on your website and it says you do Jung, so I can't see you because I'm an atheist, or I can't see you because I'm a Christian. So you lose people. I was like, well, you know, I'm wondering what you're taking me using Jungian technique to mean here. That's right.
有人打电话给我，说他们想来看我，并预约了。然后他们说，我在你的网站上看到你做荣格分析，所以我不能来看你，因为我是无神论者，或者因为我是基督徒。所以你会失去一些人。我说，嗯，我想知道你在这里所说的“使用荣格技术”是什么意思。没错。
Yeah. So the problem with Jung now in the universities, you don't find Jung in the universities at all anymore. I think there was a stage back in the 20s and 30s where American universities were very interested in Jung. In fact, Freud and Jung used to go to America. In the 70s, it was everywhere. Yeah. Campbell wasn't too upfront about his influences, though. I mean, he doesn't point people back to where he got a lot of his ideas, which I think is... Campbell. Yeah, I dislike that about Campbell. I mean, most of his ideas are completely borrowed
是的。所以荣格现在在大学里的问题是，你再也找不到荣格了。我认为在20年代和30年代，美国大学对荣格非常感兴趣。事实上，弗洛伊德和荣格过去常去美国。在70年代，他到处都是。是的。不过坎贝尔对他的影响来源并不太坦诚。我的意思是，他没有把人们引向他获得许多想法的地方，我认为这是……坎贝尔。是的，我不喜欢坎贝尔这一点。我的意思是，他大部分的想法完全是从荣格那里借来的，
from Jung. But yet there is an American idea that America is a source country and doesn't like always to acknowledge that many of its so-called original ideas came from Europe. So I think that's a problem. That's part of the American complex is that it is original. And original thinking is important to it. The rugged individualism and that we are the source of culture for the world. Yes, exactly. Which is true in part about the US.
但美国有一种观念，认为美国是一个源头国家，不喜欢总是承认其许多所谓的原创思想来自欧洲。所以我认为这是一个问题。这是美国情结的一部分，即它是原创的。原创思维对它很重要。那种粗犷的个人主义，以及我们是世界文化的源头。是的，完全正确。这在某种程度上对美国来说是真实的。
I'm not wishing to be too critical, but I think that Jung's influence on Campbell and Jung's influence on people like Robert Bly and Jordan Peterson, that's another topic, and James Hillman is enormous, but there's a certain reluctance to admit. Mircea Eliade is another one who was very reluctant to admit to the public that he was hugely influenced by Jung. I was wondering, you know, before we get off the topic of religion or take a break from it. If there's an idea you know you're talking about Jung
我不想显得太吹毛求疵，但我认为荣格对坎贝尔的影响，以及荣格对罗伯特·布莱和乔丹·彼得森等人的影响——那是另一个话题了——还有詹姆斯·希尔曼，这种影响是巨大的，但人们有一种不愿承认的倾向。米尔恰·伊利亚德也是如此，他非常不愿向公众承认自己深受荣格的影响。我在想，你知道，在我们结束宗教这个话题或暂时休息一下之前，如果你有什么想法，你知道，你正在谈论荣格
kind of independently discovering probably a lot like Eckhart you know this eastern idea. Could you say a little bit about the relationship in a Jungian conception between the self, not the ego, but the deep and aware self and God or the reality of God, because there is a relationship that is interesting in the Jungian tradition between those, but it is kind of hard to explain it. It is. Jung's model is completely based on Hinduism, which he was really influenced by. And in Hinduism, the self, as I said before, is called the Atman, A-T-M-A-N. And the Atman is regarded as the place in the human being,
某种程度上是独立发现的，可能很像埃克哈特，你知道，这种东方思想。你能谈谈荣格概念中“自我”（不是小我，而是深层且有觉知的自我）与上帝或上帝的现实之间的关系吗？因为在荣格传统中，这两者之间的关系很有趣，但确实很难解释。确实如此。荣格的模型完全基于印度教，他深受其影响。在印度教中，正如我之前所说，自我被称为“阿特曼”（Atman），A-T-M-A-N。阿特曼被认为是人类身上那个地方，
so to speak. I mean, I'm using the word place metaphorically, but the place in the human being, so to speak. I mean, I'm using the word place metaphorically, but the place in the human being which is in touch with Brahma, which is God. So the relationship between Atman and Brahma is very similar in Christianity to relationship between God the Son and God the Father. But in Christianity, of course, the whole idea of the Atman, as it were,
可以这么说。我的意思是，我是在隐喻地使用“地方”这个词，但可以这么说，它是人类身上那个与梵（Brahma，即上帝）相通的地方。所以，阿特曼与梵之间的关系，在基督教中与圣子与圣父之间的关系非常相似。但在基督教中，当然，阿特曼的整个概念，可以说，
is projected onto the Jesus Christ figure, and only he has this special close relationship to God the Father. So this was never even conceived as a possibility in Hinduism because they always felt that the relationship between the human being and Brahma or God is closer than it gets in Christianity. So there are, of course, Hindu Christians who respect and appreciate the Christian story, but Hinduism itself is really, I guess, it's a form of mysticism. So this is the thing that fascinates me, that the East doesn't need to develop mysticisms
被投射到了耶稣基督身上，只有他才与圣父有这种特殊的亲密关系。所以这在印度教中甚至从未被视为一种可能性，因为他们一直认为人类与梵或上帝之间的关系比基督教中所描述的要亲密得多。当然，也有尊重和欣赏基督教故事的印度教基督徒，但印度教本身，我想，它是一种神秘主义。所以这让我着迷，东方不需要发展神秘主义
which can complement their orthodoxies, whereas in the West, in both, well, the three Abrahamic religions, Christianity, Judaism, and Islam, in order to get that closeness or proximity between the human and the God, we have to develop mysticisms. So, you know, Jewish Kabbalah, for instance, the Christian mystical tradition and the Islamic tradition of Sufism develop because of the need to compensate the Orthodox traditions, which tend to place the human
来补充他们的正统教义，而在西方，在三种亚伯拉罕宗教——基督教、犹太教和伊斯兰教中，为了获得人类与上帝之间的那种亲近感，我们必须发展神秘主义。所以，你知道，比如犹太卡巴拉、基督教神秘主义传统和伊斯兰苏菲主义传统的产生，是因为需要补偿那些倾向于将人类
and the God far apart. But in both Hinduism and Buddhism, the two major Eastern religions, there is no need to complement the orthodoxies because they're already mysticisms. The path is there, but if you're dealing with Islam or Christianity, you need to build the path to have the direct experience to God because the tradition is there to keep it away from you to give you a hierarchy and a structure and a container and if you hang out there long enough maybe you get bored with the container and you want to crack that open and leave the ego and so then you have to have
与上帝远远隔开的正统传统。但在印度教和佛教这两大东方宗教中，没有必要补充正统教义，因为它们本身就是神秘主义。道路就在那里，但如果你处理的是伊斯兰教或基督教，你需要建立通往上帝的直接体验之路，因为传统存在的作用就是让你远离它，给你一个等级制度、一个结构和一个容器。如果你在那里待得够久，也许你会对这个容器感到厌倦，想要打破它，离开小我，所以你就必须拥有
you know a mystical pathway that out of the literal interpretation. That's exactly right. But Catholicism has made an interesting breakthrough on this, and particularly from the theologian Karl Rahner, R-A-H-N-E-R, the German Catholic theologian who was very influential in the Vatican II Council in the 1960s. And Vatican II Council plus Karl Rahner said that the future Christian must be a mystical person or won't be at all. So Catholicism almost seemingly in a turnabout, you know, an about face, has this idea that it itself should become more mystical.
你知道，一种脱离字面解释的神秘主义路径。完全正确。但天主教在这方面取得了有趣的突破，特别是神学家卡尔·拉内（Karl Rahner，R-A-H-N-E-R），这位德国天主教神学家在20世纪60年代的第二次梵蒂冈大公会议中非常有影响力。第二次梵蒂冈大公会议加上卡尔·拉内说，未来的基督徒必须是一个神秘主义者，否则就根本不是基督徒。所以天主教几乎在某种程度上来了一个大转弯，你知道，一个彻底的转变，认为它本身应该变得更加神秘。
That's what it said in Vatican II Council in the early 60s. But, of course, what happened was that most bishops, archbishops and cardinals didn't agree with this radical finding of Vatican II Council, so they kind of protested against it. So we find in the Catholic Church today very few priests who actually believe in this mystical direction. They want to restore the old hierarchy. They want to restore power of the clergy. Because, of course, if individuals have a mystical connection to God, then really the clergy and its hierarchy is irrelevant. If you don't make room for that, the priests leave you know they leave the tradition when you're not allowing uh that mystical pathway to exist simultaneously with the people who need the literalism and the people who need the
这就是60年代初第二次梵蒂冈大公会议所说的。但是，当然，发生的事情是大多数主教、大主教和红衣主教不同意第二次梵蒂冈大公会议的这一激进发现，所以他们对此进行了抗议。因此，我们今天在天主教会中发现，真正相信这种神秘主义方向的神职人员很少。他们想恢复旧的等级制度。他们想恢复神职人员的权力。因为，当然，如果个人与上帝有神秘的联系，那么神职人员及其等级制度就变得无关紧要了。如果你不为此留出空间，神职人员就会离开，你知道，当你不允许那种神秘主义路径与那些需要字面主义的人同时存在时，他们就会离开传统，而那些需要
so that's right so that's why the catholic church is in a bit of a chaotic state at the moment because in the 60s the vatican ii council was said to be a movement of the Holy Spirit. And in one of the encyclicals called The Word of God, Verbum Deo, it actually says that we want to change Catholicism to being a religion about God, to a religion of God. So they wanted to bring this they could see that that the world especially the western world and educated people no longer wanted this kind of second-hand religion they wanted the first-hand experience and that of course is what Jung was saying all along. So Catholicism said that and then it backtracked fiercely with a huge backlash from conservative bishops. Well, the people who are kind of the most reactionary Catholics, a lot of the time that memorize all the rules and can calculate exactly how much time you spend in purgatory for each crime and sin and all that. They're the converts. But the communities that have been Catholic for a long time,
所以没错，这就是为什么天主教会目前处于一种混乱状态，因为在60年代，第二次梵蒂冈大公会议被认为是圣灵的运动。在一份名为《天主圣言》（Verbum Deo）的通谕中，它实际上说我们想把天主教从一种关于上帝的宗教，转变为一种上帝的宗教。所以他们想带来这一点，他们能看出世界，特别是西方世界和受过教育的人，不再想要这种二手宗教，他们想要一手体验，而这当然就是荣格一直所说的。所以天主教说了这些，然后又在保守派主教的强烈抵制下猛烈倒退。嗯，那些最反动的天主教徒，很多时候是那些背诵所有规则，能精确计算出你在炼狱中为每项罪行和罪孽花费多少时间的人。他们是皈依者。但那些长期信奉天主教的社区，
they tend to develop that transcendental pathway through the saints a lot of the time. And then you get the saints functioning similar to the way that in Hinduism, the different gods function as there is one God, but this is a manifestation of one need for God. Ganesha, the elephant is elephants are construction equipment it will remove the obstacle for you and you see you know different cultural groups have festival the saints start to function that way when you spend time in that world the saints do act as intermediaries i think is the word that we're looking for here and Mary, Virgin Mary, Mother of God, Mother of Jesus is of course in Catholicism seen as a mediary, a way if you like. I mean in the beginning Christianity was called
他们往往通过圣徒来发展那种超验的路径。然后你会发现圣徒的功能类似于印度教中不同神祇的功能，即只有一个上帝，但这是对上帝需求的一种显化。象头神，大象是建筑设备，它会为你移除障碍，你看，不同的文化群体有节日，当你花时间在那个世界里时，圣徒确实起到了中介的作用，我想这是我们在这里要找的词，而玛丽，圣母玛利亚，上帝之母，耶稣之母，在天主教中当然被视为一种中介，如果你愿意的话，一种方式。我的意思是，起初基督教被称为
The Way, capital W, and it lost that as hierarchy, dogma and doctrine sort of took over and it became, as you said before, virtually became a way to keep people from God, you know, to protect people from a potentially disorienting direct experience with God. And that's what Jung says in his book, Psychology and Religion, that the West partly feared direct contact with the source of our being because it thought it might be utterly disorienting and even dismembering of people. So... Well, Edinger has that great map and ego and archetype
“道路”（The Way，大写W），随着等级制度、教条和教义的接管，它失去了这一点，正如你之前所说，它实际上变成了一种让人们远离上帝的方式，你知道，为了保护人们免受与上帝直接接触可能带来的迷失感。这就是荣格在他的书《心理学与宗教》中所说的，西方部分地害怕与我们存在的源头直接接触，因为它认为这可能会让人彻底迷失，甚至让人支离破碎。所以……嗯，埃丁格在《自我与原型》中有那张很棒的地图，
where, you know, are you familiar with the diagram where he says, like, this is the functioning church and the archetypes are being held by the container, but then when it breaks down, everyone is having a direct experience, but they're not ready for it. And it starts to look like psychosis if you're not ready for it.
你知道，你熟悉那张图表吗？他说，这是运作中的教会，原型被容器所容纳，但当它崩溃时，每个人都在进行直接体验，但他们还没有准备好。如果你没有准备好，它看起来就像精神病。
And you look at political developments like QAnon or these things where people are engaging you know that aren't quite ready with this archetypal stuff and it's there's a rootlessness there's no container there's no hierarchy there's they're not ready and you know a lot of american certain kinds of american political and religious belief are starting to look just a lot like schizophrenia, you know, in the broad strokes of how they function. No, that's right. And that's why Jung was in two minds about all this. You know, one part of him admired the Christian churches for presenting what he called a bulwark against direct experience. He liked that idea because it protected people. I mean, the American writer Annie Dillard has written extensively about this.
你看看像“匿名者Q”（QAnon）这样的政治发展，或者人们参与的那些事情，你知道，他们还没有完全准备好面对这些原型的东西，这是一种无根性，没有容器，没有等级制度，他们没有准备好，你知道，许多美国某种特定的政治和宗教信仰开始看起来非常像精神分裂症，你知道，从它们运作的大致轮廓来看。不，那是对的。这就是为什么荣格对这一切持两种态度。你知道，他的一部分钦佩基督教会，因为它呈现了他所说的抵御直接体验的堡垒。他喜欢这个想法，因为它保护了人们。我的意思是，美国作家安妮·迪拉德对此写了很多。
Do you know Annie Dillard? I'm not familiar. No, she's written a number of books. And one of her books, she says, people in churches who ask the Holy Spirit to come down upon them and bless them have no idea what they're asking for. And she says they should wear safety helmets on their heads in case what they're asking for actually does happen. And they should go in with those bicycle helmets hard hats and she's a mystical writer in the United States and I love her work very much teaching a stone to talk as one of her books yeah I have heard that title Yeah, and another book is called, I think it's called Holy Ground, Holy the Ground, something like that. And she obviously is on the same page here as Jung.
你认识安妮·迪拉德吗？我不熟悉。不，她写过很多书。在她的其中一本书里，她说，在教堂里祈求圣灵降临并祝福他们的人，根本不知道他们在祈求什么。她说他们应该戴上安全帽，以防他们祈求的事情真的发生。他们应该戴着那种自行车头盔、安全帽进去，她是一位美国的神秘主义作家，我非常喜欢她的作品，《教石头说话》是她的书之一。是的，我听过那个书名。是的，还有另一本书叫，我想叫《圣地，神圣的土地》，类似这样的。她显然和荣格在同一页上。
And Jung says that Christianity is dying because people aren't having first-hand experiences of the source of their being and that the church is too much of a bulwark and a defensive wall against direct experience. But as you said, people who want direct experience can end up and do end up, schizophrenic. Because we're not used to it, you see. We're not used to it.
荣格说基督教正在消亡，因为人们没有获得他们存在源头的一手体验，而且教会作为抵御直接体验的堡垒和防御墙太厚了。但正如你所说，想要直接体验的人最终可能会，也确实会，变得精神分裂。因为我们不习惯，你看。我们不习惯。
We don't have the values. The ego is that organizing principle of the psyche. When you get rid of it entirely, there is no organizing principle. You know, something like Newman talking about centraversion and the process that when when animals are evolving you know into humans there are all these instinctual reactions and there get to be so many there needs to be a central principle that can choose between them and when you just completely just destroy that um you're you're not functioning. So Jung used to say that the West is ahead of the East
我们没有那些价值观。小我是心灵的组织原则。当你完全摆脱它时，就没有组织原则了。你知道，像纽曼谈论“中心化”（centraversion）以及那个过程，当动物进化成人类时，有所有这些本能反应，当它们变得太多时，就需要一个能在它们之间进行选择的中心原则，而当你完全摧毁它时，嗯，你就无法运作了。所以荣格过去常说，西方在技术和科学上领先于东方，
with technology and science, but the East is way ahead of the West in terms of religion, mysticism, and the numinous, you know, the experience of the divine. And I think that in the East, in India in particular, and also, of course, Tibet, China's in a different position because it's been officially atheist since Mao Zedong, although I can see a reaction happening quite soon in China as people are not going to be happy with this atheism. But when you go to China and you ask them what their religion is, they're like, well, we're atheists,
但在宗教、神秘主义和神圣体验（numinous）方面，东方远远领先于西方。我认为在东方，特别是在印度，当然还有西藏，中国处于不同的位置，因为它自毛泽东以来在官方上是无神论的，尽管我可以看到中国很快会发生一种反弹，因为人们不会对这种无神论感到满意。但当你去中国问他们宗教是什么时，他们会说，嗯，我们是无神论者，
and then we're going to burn all this paper money so that our ancestral spirit can have it in the afterlife during the funeral, and then we're going to, and you're like, wait a minute, so you do, no, no, no, we're atheists, we're communists, we're atheists, and they'll continue to tell you about, and I mean, Americans do the same thing. When you turn mythology into something that is scary and of the past, you're blind to how it is Chinese in my city. So it's just under a half a million Chinese in my city alone.
然后我们要烧掉所有这些纸钱，以便我们的祖先灵魂在葬礼期间能在来世得到它，然后我们要……你会说，等一下，所以你们确实……不，不，不，我们是无神论者，我们是共产主义者，我们是无神论者，然后他们会继续告诉你关于……我的意思是，美国人也做同样的事情。当你把神话变成某种可怕的、过去的东西时，你就看不见它在我的城市里是如何中国化的。所以仅在我的城市里就有不到五十万中国人。
The reason they're here is because the standard of living here is very high. In fact, the standard of living in Australia, if you don't mind me saying, is higher than America. Sure. Because we have free public health. You know, you can go and see the doctor and it all is free. We don't have that fiasco that you had about Obamacare and things like that.
他们在这里的原因是因为这里的生活水平很高。事实上，如果你不介意我这么说，澳大利亚的生活水平比美国还要高。当然。因为我们有免费的公共医疗。你知道，你可以去看医生，而且这一切都是免费的。我们没有你们那种关于奥巴马医改之类的闹剧。
We have a system which is quite similar to Sweden. Health services are free and there's lots of doctors and lots of nurses. And, of course, food here is relatively cheap compared to China where it's expensive. So a lot of Chinese are coming here. But I've met several Chinese. I had quite a few Chinese students when I taught at the university.
我们有一个与瑞典相当相似的系统。医疗服务是免费的，有很多医生和护士。而且，当然，这里的食物与中国相比相对便宜，在中国食物很贵。所以很多中国人来到这里。但我见过几个中国人。我在大学教书时有相当多的中国学生。
And, yes, I'd ask them, do they have a religion? And the first answer was always no because they're supposed to be atheists. But after you talk to them a bit, they say they pray to the deities and that they light incense and candles and have intermediaries that they worship. So it's a kind of a schizophrenic culture, really, or perhaps that's a bit harsh. It's the same as America.
是的，我会问他们是否有宗教信仰。第一个回答总是“没有”，因为他们被要求成为无神论者。但在你和他们聊了一会儿之后，他们说他们向神灵祈祷，他们点香和蜡烛，并且有他们崇拜的中介。所以这确实是一种精神分裂的文化，或者也许那样说有点苛刻。这和美国是一样的。
You turn everything into a religion, and then you don't see religion anymore. And so people aren't aware that their politics have become that. Even atheism is like a religion in the United States. When someone becomes an atheist they have to be enlightened and they're superior and they're very freudian and intellectual and it's like your whole life is about this lack of belief in something that is itself a religion you were creating it's a religion in its particularly in its dogmatism and the way it can you know basically shapes your whole life but i've i've found with the the chinese that it's almost like
你把一切都变成了宗教，然后你就再也看不见宗教了。所以人们没有意识到他们的政治已经变成了那样。在美国，甚至无神论也像一种宗教。当某人成为无神论者时，他们必须变得开明，他们是优越的，他们非常弗洛伊德式且理智，这就像你的整个生活都是关于这种对某种东西的缺乏信仰，而这本身就是一种宗教，你正在创造它，它是一种宗教，特别是在它的教条主义以及它基本上塑造你整个生活的方式上，但我发现中国人的情况几乎就像
to use yong in terms the persona versus the soul you know the persona of the chinese is atheist but the soul is not atheist and never has been and so this suggests that china is a very dangerous country because if the persona and the soul are out of whack and they don't actually relate to each other, then the potential for splitting of the personality, the schizophrenia or dissociation is always there. That's happened to my sister. She, like me, was brought up very religious. I had a totally full-on religious
用荣格的术语来说，人格面具（persona）与灵魂（soul）的对比，你知道，中国人的面具是无神论者，但灵魂不是无神论者，也从来都不是。所以这表明中国是一个非常危险的国家，因为如果面具和灵魂不一致，它们实际上没有关联，那么人格分裂、精神分裂或解离的可能性就总是存在的。我姐姐就发生过这种情况。她像我一样，是在非常虔诚的环境中长大的。我有一个完全彻底的宗教
upbringing, and so did my sister. She rejected it intellectually as she became more educated. She read existentialism and Freud and Nietzsche, and she got me reading existentialism when I was about 17, which was probably too young to understand existentialism. But after a while, she clung to this atheist idea and became progressively schizophrenic. And I did speak to her about it, and she thought I was part of the devil because she developed paranoia. But my family uh is irish and the irish are inherently religious you know no two ways about it
成长经历，我姐姐也是。随着她受教育程度的提高，她在理智上拒绝了它。她读了存在主义、弗洛伊德和尼采，我在17岁左右时她让我读存在主义，那可能太年轻了，无法理解存在主义。但过了一段时间，她执着于这种无神论思想，并逐渐变得精神分裂。我确实和她谈过这件事，她认为我是魔鬼的一部分，因为她产生了偏执。但我的家庭是爱尔兰裔，爱尔兰人天生就是虔诚的，你知道，毫无疑问，
um if you say you're atheist in ireland you're basically lying you're trying to be an atheist but your soul is still religious so with my sister she said she was atheist but actually she she was of the same psyche that i had and i can't get rid of religion i can i've tried to but i can't and i don't want to anymore because well i don't know that anyone can it's the are you honest about it and how it is functioning in your life are you conscious of that i mean going back to China, you know, the persona can turn on a dime,
嗯，如果你在爱尔兰说你是无神论者，你基本上是在撒谎，你试图成为一名无神论者，但你的灵魂仍然是虔诚的。所以对于我姐姐，她说她是无神论者，但实际上她和我拥有同样的心理，我无法摆脱宗教，我试过，但我做不到，而且我也不想再这样做了，因为……嗯，我不知道是否有人能做到。这是关于你是否诚实，以及它在你的生活中是如何运作的，你是否意识到这一点。我的意思是回到中国，你知道，面具可以瞬间改变，
but the soul can't, you know, you have this modernist Marxist cultural project where you come in and say, okay, everybody's atheist. Now this is what you believe. And this is this new way of life. You can do that in 50 years,
但灵魂不能，你知道，你有这个现代主义的马克思主义文化项目，你进来并说，好吧，每个人都是无神论者。现在这就是你的信仰。这就是这种新的生活方式。你可以在50年内做到这一点，
but you can't get rid of the history. The, the body, like the, the, that is still this felt rootedness. Thousands of years, thousands of years. Ancestor worship and families. The body, that is still this felt rootedness. Thousands of years.
但你无法摆脱历史。身体，就像那个，那仍然是这种被感受到的根源。几千年来，几千年来。祖先崇拜和家庭。身体，那仍然是这种被感受到的根源。几千年来。
Thousands of years. Ancestor worship and families. Ancestor worship and Buddhism as well. Apparently, Richard Wilhelm, as we say in English, wrote a book in the 40s called The Soul of China. But, of course, he wrote it before Mao Zedong. And a friend of mine is sending me this book. It's in the mail now.
几千年来。祖先崇拜和家庭。祖先崇拜和佛教也是。显然，理查德·威廉（Richard Wilhelm），正如我们用英语所说，在40年代写了一本名为《中国之魂》的书。但当然，他在毛泽东之前就写了它。我的一位朋友正在给我寄这本书。它现在在邮寄途中。
I can't wait to read it because I think The Soul of China is going to come up again. And when that comes up again, we're going to get a very different China to the one we see today with Xi Jinping as the presiding oligarch over the whole thing, 1.6 billion people, which makes America look small in terms of the population. And as for my country, you know, we have fewer people than you have in California. And so we're sitting at the foot of China.
我迫不及待地想读它，因为我认为《中国之魂》会再次出现。当它再次出现时，我们将看到一个与我们今天看到的由习近平作为整个事情的最高寡头、16亿人口的中国非常不同的中国，这使得美国在人口方面看起来很小。至于我的国家，你知道，我们的人口比你们加州的人口还要少。所以我们坐在中国的脚下。
There's sheep farms in Australia that are the size of Alabama with very few people on them. Well, when I lived in America, they called Australia British Texans. Yeah. We have wide horizons with nothing in them, massive continent. It's the same size as America geographically without Alaska. But we only have 24 million people in this massive country. And so we are, I think, quite afraid of China because it's in an aggressive expansionist mood at the moment.
澳大利亚有像阿拉巴马州那么大的养羊场，上面几乎没有人。嗯，当我住在美国时，他们称澳大利亚为“英国德克萨斯人”。是的。我们有广阔的地平线，上面什么都没有，巨大的大陆。它在地理上和美国一样大，不包括阿拉斯加。但在这个巨大的国家里，我们只有2400万人。所以，我认为我们非常害怕中国，因为它目前处于一种咄咄逼人的扩张主义情绪中。
It's clearly already moved on Hong Kong, taken it back, and it's about to, of course, despite Nancy Pelosi's visits, take Taiwan back that's expressed policy current Chinese political strategy and of course they will probably come closer they took over South Vietnam and of course as you well know America fought that war and lost it and supported america fighting against the communists from the north when there's a lot of building projects and things in africa you know that where they're building hospitals roads bridges for memoir rights and there was a funny twitter exchange a couple months ago where somebody was like the chinese are you know the africans want the chinese to come
它显然已经对香港采取了行动，收回了它，当然，尽管南希·佩洛西访问了，它也即将收回台湾，这是当前中国明确的政治战略，当然他们可能会走得更近，他们接管了南越，当然正如你所知，美国打了那场战争并输了，并支持美国对抗来自北方的共产主义者，当非洲有很多建筑项目和事情时，你知道，他们正在为……建设医院、道路、桥梁，几个月前有一个有趣的推特交流，有人说中国人，你知道，非洲人想要中国人来，
they don't want the americans and the british And the saying is when the Chinese come, we get a hospital. When the Americans and the British come, we get a lecture. And a British and an American person responded on the thing. And they said, well, you have to understand there's no such thing as a free lunch. And then an African said, there goes the lecture. That is so funny. That is so true. Australiansians are like americans you know we we happily give out lectures to countries you know like africa african there's i think you give
他们不想要美国人和英国人。俗话说，当中国人来时，我们得到了一家医院。当美国人和英国人来时，我们得到了一场讲座。一位英国人和一位美国人在上面回应了。他们说，嗯，你必须明白，天下没有免费的午餐。然后一个非洲人说，讲座来了。这太搞笑了。这太真实了。澳大利亚人就像美国人，你知道，我们很高兴地向非洲这样的国家发表讲座，我想你给
out a little bit more health care than the states so and the british too give them lectures but america china wants to build hospitals and schools not only only Africa, but this is all the Pacific Islands, like Samoa, Fiji, all these countries in the Pacific. China wants them as strategic bases for their expansionist policy. This expansionist policy is for some reason called the Belt and Road, the Belt and Road policy. road policy and of course naturally america is shaking in its boots because of the world order and and our mythology is under threat that no one can world order is under threat no one can do anything without us approving of it
出的医疗保健比美国多一点，所以英国人也给他们讲座，但美国……中国想要建造医院和学校，不仅是在非洲，而且是在太平洋岛屿，像萨摩亚、斐济，所有这些太平洋国家。中国想要它们作为其扩张主义政策的战略基地。这种扩张主义政策出于某种原因被称为“一带一路”，一带一路政策。当然，美国自然因为世界秩序而吓得发抖，我们的神话受到威胁，没有人能……世界秩序受到威胁，没有人能在没有我们批准的情况下做任何事情，
and and that myth is ending and we do amer Americans resist making a new myth, you know. Yes, the American myth is basically that it rules the world, you know, that it's the policeman of the world. And China's in the process of challenging that and already has outmaneuvered with America in terms of its gross national product and its economic development so australia is one of the very close allies of america um is shaking because we're wondering we're wondering if we've made allies with the wrong country we made allies with america after
那个神话正在终结，我们美国人抵制创造一个新的神话，你知道。是的，美国的神话基本上是它统治世界，你知道，它是世界的警察。中国正在挑战这一点，并且在国民生产总值和经济发展方面已经超过了美国，所以澳大利亚作为美国非常亲密的盟友之一，正在发抖，因为我们在想，我们在想我们是否与错误的国家结盟了，我们在……之后与美国结盟
the second world war america saved australia the Japanese, just as it saved Europe from Hitler. As well, America did a massive amount of good work in the Second World War, but its Pacific theatre was focused on helping Australia save our country, and they did a marvellous job. But now we're wondering whether we need a better alliance with china so we too feel totally confused about the world order but we're talking politics now the religious thing is bubbling away under the surface, you know, I mean. Always. Always. And it's hard to know what the answer will be about China
第二次世界大战，美国拯救了澳大利亚免受日本人的侵害，就像它拯救欧洲免受希特勒的侵害一样。同样，美国在第二次世界大战中做了大量出色的工作，但它的太平洋战区专注于帮助澳大利亚拯救我们的国家，他们做得非常出色。但现在我们想知道我们是否需要与中国建立更好的联盟，所以我们也对世界秩序感到完全困惑，但我们现在在谈论政治，宗教的东西在表面下冒泡，你知道，我的意思是。总是。总是。而且很难知道关于中国的答案会是什么，
on the brink of some kind of religious breakthrough. I used to teach at the Jung Institute in Zurich for quite a few years, actually 10 years, and most of my students were asians um chinese japanese uh thailand taiwan also vietnamese cambodians and koreans were there in huge numbers and i would think to myself you know what's going on in Asia? Why are they so hungry for Jung? And the biggest pop band in the world is called BTS, and their work is all based on Jung.
处于某种宗教突破的边缘。我过去在苏黎世的荣格学院教书好几年，实际上是10年，我的大多数学生都是亚洲人，嗯，中国人、日本人、泰国人、台湾人，还有越南人、柬埔寨人和韩国人，人数众多，我会想，你知道，亚洲发生了什么？为什么他们如此渴望荣格？世界上最流行的乐队叫BTS，他们的作品全部基于荣格。
They've released a series of albums based on the book by Murray Stein called The Map of the Soul. They released an album called The Map of the Soul. They released an album called The Persona and then something called Archetypes and something about soul, and that's the biggest selling band in the world. So there's some very extraordinary things going on in Asia at the moment. And, of course, in Russia there are extraordinary things too. The Russian Orthodox Church has re-bonded
他们发行了一系列基于默里·斯坦（Murray Stein）所著《灵魂地图》（The Map of the Soul）一书的专辑。他们发行了一张名为《灵魂地图》的专辑。他们发行了一张名为《人格面具》的专辑，然后是某种叫《原型》的东西，还有关于灵魂的东西，那是世界上销量最大的乐队。所以亚洲目前正在发生一些非常非凡的事情。当然，在俄罗斯也有非凡的事情。俄罗斯东正教教会已经重新与
with the Russian government. So there's no connection, disconnect anymore between the Russian Church and the Russian state. So, you know, this is an extraordinary thing um which was unprecedented and we used to think of russia as a secular country and a communist of course based on marx but now i think the marxist stuff's flying away quickly and there's this sort of fundamentalist fusion between religion and the state and Russia is a very dangerous country of course always has been probably always will be so the whole world order is shifting under our feet well it's a dangerous world I mean I think
俄罗斯政府结合。所以俄罗斯教会和俄罗斯国家之间不再有联系，不再有脱节。所以，你知道，这是一件非凡的事情，嗯，这是前所未有的，我们过去认为俄罗斯是一个世俗国家，当然是基于马克思的共产主义，但现在我认为马克思主义的东西正在迅速飞走，并且在宗教和国家之间存在这种原教旨主义的融合，俄罗斯当然是一个非常危险的国家，可能永远都会是这样，所以整个世界秩序正在我们脚下发生变化，嗯，这是一个危险的世界，我的意思是，我认为
the bigger through line in our conversation has been the benefits and the risks of direct experience. And I know that you have said that you're not super comfortable talking about clinical realities or therapy. But at the same time, I mean, I don't know why you feel like you know more about therapy than probably most clinicians, at least the ones that send resumes to me. And like the... now now now well people know i'm not and i'm not saying that they're not good clinicians it's that we don't
我们谈话中更大的主线一直是直接体验的好处和风险。我知道你说过你不太舒服谈论临床现实或治疗。但与此同时，我的意思是，我不知道为什么你觉得你比大多数临床医生更了解治疗，至少是那些给我发简历的人。而且像……现在，现在，现在，嗯，人们知道我不是，我并不是说他们不是好的临床医生，而是我们不
teach the history of the profession i mean we cognitive behavioral therapy came in in the 80s and and it's just the ego is all there is here's some ego management strategies you know clap your hands and tell the anxiety to stop and i mean what i notice too is like the institutes the union institutes in the 80s become incredibly analytical i mean they're analyzing trauma but they're not treating it and they're you know somebody who's has a dissociative disorder you're telling them about the myth of pericles you know but you're not doing any kind of direct experience there's this distance and then in those out of those institutes a lot of people a lot of union analysts leave of Pericles, you know, but you're not doing any kind of direct experience. There's this distance. And then in those, out of those institutes, a lot of people, a lot of Jungian analysts leave, like Arnold Mendel, and he does process therapy, and Sidra and Hal Stone that do voice dialogue.
教授这个专业的历史，我的意思是，认知行为疗法在80年代出现，而这只是小我的一切，这里有一些小我管理策略，你知道，拍拍手，告诉焦虑停止，我的意思是，我也注意到的是，像研究所，80年代的荣格研究所变得非常分析，我的意思是，他们正在分析创伤，但他们没有治疗它，他们，你知道，有人患有解离性障碍，你告诉他们伯里克利的神话，你知道，但你没有做任何直接体验，有一种距离感，然后从那些研究所里，很多人，很多荣格分析师离开了，像伯里克利，你知道，但你没有做任何直接体验。有一种距离感。然后从那些研究所里，很多人，很多荣格分析师离开了，像阿诺德·明德尔（Arnold Mendel），他做了过程疗法，还有西德拉和哈尔·斯通（Sidra and Hal Stone）做声音对话。
And the thing that those have in common is that they're directly experiential, they're not analytical styles, they're based on Jung's map. But then also they're somatic, they're using the body you know can you say anything about that or do you know anything about that the point with the institutes well I think you're right and I think there's been a book recently written about this which I mentioned before Peter Kingsley Not familiar. Catafalque. Catafalque is something to do with the ceremonies in funerals. The book, subtitled the book, is C.G. Jung and the End of Humanity, which is a rather dramatic-sounding title. But I think that the Jungian project is in danger of if not already has lost
这些共同点是它们是直接体验式的，它们不是分析风格，它们基于荣格的地图。但它们也是躯体化的，它们在使用身体，你知道，你能对此说些什么吗？或者你知道关于那个研究所的重点吗？嗯，我想你是对的，而且我认为最近有一本书写了这个，我之前提到过，彼得·金斯利（Peter Kingsley）。不熟悉。《Catafalque》。Catafalque与葬礼上的仪式有关。这本书，副标题是《C.G.荣格与人类的终结》，这是一个听起来相当戏剧性的标题。但我认为荣格项目如果不是已经失去了，就有危险
its soul actually there's a lot of infighting in the institutes i don't know the politics behind those but there's like three competing ones now where people left and made their own and i mean well in london which i'm very familiar with because I'm often in London there are five competing Jungian institutes it's already a small piece of clinicians are Jungian I mean to be cutting this into fractions seems like a Freud had a wonderful phrase for this he called it the narcissism of minor differences and I'm working for next week i'm actually working for one of the london institutes and they're sort of not friendly with the other yungian institutes so it's just disagreements i mean why do they fight these fighting this fighting indicates the field is fragmented to say the least and they're being fragmented how can it function properly
它的灵魂，实际上研究所里有很多内斗，我不知道背后的政治，但现在有三个相互竞争的，人们离开了并建立了他们自己的，我的意思是，嗯，在伦敦，我很熟悉，因为我经常在伦敦，有五个相互竞争的荣格研究所，临床医生中只有一小部分是荣格派的，我的意思是，把这个分成几部分似乎像……弗洛伊德对此有一个美妙的短语，他称之为“微小差异的自恋”，我下周要为其中一个伦敦研究所工作，他们对其他荣格研究所不太友好，所以这只是分歧，我的意思是，他们为什么要打架？这种打架表明该领域至少是碎片化的，而且正在被碎片化，它怎么能正常运作？
so I think you're right and a lot of people that get disillusioned with Jungian clinical training for instance I was giving a series of lectures last month in October 2022 and there was a fellow who came on who was studying at the Jung Institute in Zurich, and I was giving contextual lectures about where Jung had come from, what are the major influences on his thinking from Germany and, of course, Switzerland and France, et cetera. And he said at the end that they never get taught that at the Jung Institute.
所以我认为你是对的，很多对荣格临床培训感到幻灭的人，例如，我上个月，2022年10月，做了一系列讲座，有一个人来参加，他正在苏黎世的荣格学院学习，我正在做关于荣格来自哪里、德国、当然还有瑞士和法国等对他思想的主要影响的背景讲座。他在最后说，他们在荣格学院从来没有被教过这些。
They just get the kind of, these are the archetypes, this is the shadow, this is the ego. They just get that model taught to them, but they don't get the whole intellectual development. Well, that's why a lot of Jungian clinicians don't know how to apply it they know how to talk about it but I mean it's a map but you need a technique um and I think you just get stuck in analysis forever and you never directly encounter any of these things or if you do it's on accident you know um I mean one maybe good jumping off point into James Hillman in the Red Book is talking about direct experience yeah if I mean if anyone isn't familiar who's listening you know James Hillman is the first what non-provisional director of the institute and he you know by all accounts he's
他们只得到那种，这些是原型，这是阴影，这是小我。他们只被教导那个模型，但他们没有得到整个智力发展。嗯，这就是为什么很多荣格临床医生不知道如何应用它，他们知道如何谈论它，但我的意思是，它是一张地图，但你需要一种技术，嗯，我认为你只是永远陷入分析中，你从来没有直接遇到这些事情，或者如果你遇到了，那是偶然的，你知道，嗯，我的意思是，一个也许进入詹姆斯·希尔曼在《红书》中谈论直接体验的好跳板，是的，如果我的意思是，如果任何听众不熟悉，你知道，詹姆斯·希尔曼是研究所的第一位非临时主任，他，你知道，据所有人的说法，他
a very good analyst and a brilliant mind but never really deals with a lot of things going on you know maybe the father wound that brings a ton of male yungians into the yungian lens um he you know has a falling out with the institute develops archetypal theology or archetypal uh what do you call it archetypal psychology which i think no one really ever figured out how to practice it including hillman you know he came up with something that he could talk about but he couldn't even he did not know how to do it because i mean he took the idea of the self and the ego away and i mean everything that i can tell about archetypal psychology is that you basically push people into a pagan religious experience with no
是一位非常好的分析师和才华横溢的思想家，但从来没有真正处理过很多事情，你知道，也许是父亲创伤，这把大量的男性荣格派带入了荣格的视角，嗯，他，你知道，与研究所闹翻了，发展了原型神学或原型……你称它为什么？原型心理学，我认为没有人真正弄清楚如何实践它，包括希尔曼，你知道，他想出了一些他可以谈论的东西，但他甚至不知道如何去做，因为我的意思是，他把自我和小我的概念拿走了，我的意思是，我能告诉关于原型心理学的一切是，你基本上把人们推向一种异教的宗教体验，没有
intellect and no sense of self and the symbol becomes reality and i mean i could i don't know what that would do but it doesn't sound helpful and i never really found any accounts of helman even doing that as an adult you you do you know that i worked with helman for three years yeah so that was why we wanted to get your perspective what i'd heard you say before and correct me where i'm wrong here is that you know your institute had sent you to work with hillman and then hillman decided that you didn't know as much as he did and so that you couldn't guest host the radio show but he wanted to analyze you which seems kind of uh arrogant there i mean i mean people who don't have the vocabulary or the learning that i have i'm not bored by they're still interesting conversations.
智力，没有自我感，符号变成了现实，我的意思是，我不知道那会做什么，但这听起来并不有帮助，而且我从来没有真正找到任何关于希尔曼作为成年人做这件事的记录。你，你知道我曾与希尔曼一起工作了三年吗？是的，这就是为什么我们想得到你的视角。我之前听你说过，如果我错了请纠正我，你知道，你的研究所派你去和希尔曼一起工作，然后希尔曼决定你没有他知道的多，所以你不能担任广播节目的客座主持人，但他想分析你，这看起来有点……傲慢，我的意思是，我的意思是，那些没有我所拥有的词汇或学识的人，我并不感到无聊，他们仍然是有趣的对话。
I mean, that seems strange. So then he said that you should become his patient, basically. Yes. Don't forget, though, the age difference. I started working with Hillman when I was 28. I'm now 70. When I was 28 Hillman was I think 58
我的意思是，这看起来很奇怪。所以他说你应该成为他的病人，基本上。是的。不过别忘了年龄差距。我开始和希尔曼工作时是28岁。我现在70岁。当我28岁时，希尔曼我想是58岁，
so there were 30 years difference so he was a good generation or more older than me and my institution which was funded by New York Harkness Foundation in New York City
所以有30年的差距，所以他比我大了一代人还多，而我的机构是由纽约市的哈克尼斯基金会资助的，
wanted me to have conversations with Hillman that might end up in books published about so-called post-Jungian psychology. But Hillman is such a, or was such a controversial figure. He'd been, as you said, he'd been booted out of Zurich because he was too radical. Well, he also slept with a patient. He slept with a patient who happened to be the wife of a clergyman in Switzerland. It scandalized everybody. His analyst, C.A. Meyer, I mean, he was kind of in a fight with his mentor too
希望我和希尔曼进行对话，这些对话最终可能以关于所谓的后荣格心理学的书出版。但希尔曼是一个，或者曾经是一个非常有争议的人物。他，正如你所说，他因为太激进而被苏黎世踢了出来。嗯，他还和一个病人睡了。他和一个恰好是瑞士一位神职人员妻子的病人睡了。这让每个人都感到震惊。他的分析师，C.A.迈耶（C.A. Meyer），我的意思是，他也在和他的导师打架，
which was maybe why he was acting out like that did you know C.A. Meyer or anything about him? no I didn't know he seemed to not be a popular person no I didn't know C.A. Meyer I knew Marie-Louise von Franz and I met Edward Edinger and I met Robert Johnson
这也许就是他为什么那样表现的原因。你认识C.A.迈耶或关于他的任何事情吗？不，我不认识，他似乎不是一个受欢迎的人。不，我不认识C.A.迈耶。我认识玛丽-路易丝·冯·弗兰兹（Marie-Louise von Franz），我见过爱德华·埃丁格（Edward Edinger），我见过罗伯特·约翰逊（Robert Johnson），
and June Singer and all these sorts of people. Those ones are probably more fun to meet. Yeah, Thomas Moore, I think, was one of the best of the lot, actually. Tom Moore, very grounded fellow, excellent man. His writing reminds me of James Hollis. They seem similar. Yes. James Hollis is also a good friend of mine um used to live in Texas I think he lives in Washington DC now yeah beautiful
还有琼·辛格（June Singer）和所有这些类型的人。那些人可能更有趣。是的，托马斯·摩尔（Thomas Moore），我认为实际上是其中最好的之一。汤姆·摩尔，非常脚踏实地的人，优秀的人。他的写作让我想起詹姆斯·霍利斯（James Hollis）。他们看起来很相似。是的。詹姆斯·霍利斯也是我的好朋友，嗯，过去住在德克萨斯州，我想他现在住在华盛顿特区。是的，很美。
yeah Thomas Moore used to live close to me in Texas and then he moved up to i think in the boston cambridge area and um but um where were we we were saying we're talking about um just hillman being your mentor and that he was kind of a talented analyst who wanted to develop something that wasn't union that was hillmanian but i don't think he ever found the words for it no you're exactly right i don't know how you know so much about this stuff because you're a young man how do you know so much i've just read everything i mean i think the profession is you should know the history of the profession and then that means that you you read the papers these people publish and you get a sense of their psychology and you get a sense of the things going on in the institutes.
是的，托马斯·摩尔过去住在德克萨斯州离我很近的地方，然后他搬到了，我想是在波士顿剑桥地区，嗯，但是，嗯，我们刚才说到哪了？我们刚才在谈论，嗯，希尔曼作为你的导师，他是一位有才华的分析师，想要发展一些不是荣格派的东西，那是希尔曼派的，但我认为他从来没有找到合适的词来表达它。不，你是完全正确的。我不知道你怎么知道这么多关于这些东西的事情，因为你是一个年轻人，你怎么知道这么多？我只是读了一切，我的意思是，我认为这个专业，你应该知道这个专业的历史，这意味着你阅读这些人发表的论文，你对他们的心理有感觉，你对研究所里发生的事情有感觉。
You know as much as I do, so I should be interviewing you. But, you know, you're half my age. But, look, frankly, you're absolutely right. Everything you say is spot on, and that is that Hillman wanted to go beyond Jung, and he bragged about it in a fashion which I thought was a bit offensive actually. Jung was a genius.
你知道的和我知道的一样多，所以我应该采访你。但是，你知道，你只有我一半大。但是，看，坦率地说，你是完全正确的。你所说的一切都切中要害，那就是希尔曼想要超越荣格，他以一种我认为实际上有点冒犯的方式吹嘘它。荣格是一位天才。
You read things like The Soul's Code and he's talking about his discovery but not able to articulate what it is. You know, it's a trope or a truism and he's not ever, he never was really able to I think separate from Jung in a mature way. You know, you have the, this kind of father wound that brings, I mean, and Hillman, really, I wanted to lead into a larger question, which is, I mean, this maybe sounds a little controversial, but I worry for myself. I mean, do you think that male Jungians go nuts at the end of their life? Do all of them do that? Because there seem to be
你读过像《灵魂密码》这样的书，他在谈论自己的发现，却无法清晰地表达那到底是什么。你知道，这是一种陈词滥调或老生常谈，而且我认为他从未真正以一种成熟的方式与荣格分离开来。你知道，你有这种所谓的“父亲创伤”，我的意思是，希尔曼，我真的想引出一个更大的问题，这听起来可能有点争议，但我为自己感到担忧。我的意思是，你认为男性荣格派学者在生命尽头会发疯吗？他们所有人都会这样吗？因为似乎有
a lot of people who, you know, they have an over-identified anima, you know, they have heightened intuitive feelings since and probably some pain and they're attracted to this psychology and then they get in it and they start to get to the end of their career and then they're angry like, well, I didn't get to save the world. did everything right i mapped all this stuff out i taught forever but the world is still a mess why am i not the messiah and and you see them i mean helen was yelling on on right wing talk radio at the end of his life about how we'd been doing therapy for 40 years and the world wasn't better so what was the point and it was like these problems have gone on since the bronze age you're not going to fix them but that isn't the reason that we try yeah i think you're right you you know too much
很多人，你知道，他们有过度认同的阿尼玛（anima），你知道，他们有增强的直觉感受，可能还有一些痛苦，他们被这种心理学所吸引，然后他们沉浸其中，开始走到职业生涯的尽头，然后他们很愤怒，就像是，好吧，我没能拯救世界。我做的一切都是对的，我规划了所有这些东西，我教了一辈子书，但世界仍然一团糟，为什么我不是弥赛亚？你会看到他们，我的意思是希尔曼在生命尽头在右翼脱口秀电台上大喊大叫，说我们做了40年的治疗，世界并没有变得更好，那意义何在？这就像这些问题从青铜时代就开始了，你不可能解决它们，但这并不是我们尝试的原因。是的，我想你是对的，你知道得太多了
oh i you you know too much i mean i i don't even need to tell you well you were there i mean i'm listening to the recordings of this you know and some torrent that i downloaded in college like a big computer recordings of this, you know, and some torrent that I downloaded in college, like a big computer file of all these Jungian talks and appearances, you know, but I don't. I think a lot of Jungian men do go a bit awry at the end of their careers. They've developed a close, as you say, an identified anima. They've often got strong intuition and feeling their
哦，你，你知道得太多了，我的意思是，我甚至不需要告诉你，好吧，你在那里，我的意思是，我正在听这些录音，你知道，我在大学里下载的一些种子文件，就像一个巨大的电脑录音文件，你知道，我在大学里下载的一些种子文件，就像一个关于所有这些荣格讲座和露面的大电脑文件，你知道，但我没有。我认为很多荣格派男性在职业生涯结束时确实有点走偏了。正如你所说，他们发展出了一种亲密的、认同的阿尼玛。他们通常有很强的直觉和情感，他们的
relationship with reality is often rather tenuous yeah um because they've been which makes them effective when they're young and it makes them yeah errors when they're dying essentially like toward the end of his life hillman i think had a deep father had a deep father wound. A deep father wound. That's why he joined up with Robert Bly, because Robert Bly trades on the father wound. And so did Moore. I mean, all of those guys. I mean, Moore was a little nicer than Bly, but he still had this tendency to be evangelical about the shadow. You mean Robert Moore? Robert Moore.
与现实的关系通常相当脆弱，是的，嗯，因为他们一直处于这种状态，这使他们在年轻时很有效率，而当他们快要死的时候，这使他们变得……本质上，在希尔曼生命尽头，我认为他有很深的父亲创伤。很深的父亲创伤。这就是为什么他与罗伯特·布莱（Robert Bly）联手，因为罗伯特·布莱利用父亲创伤。摩尔（Moore）也是如此。我的意思是，所有那些家伙。我的意思是，摩尔比布莱稍微好一点，但他仍然有一种对阴影（shadow）表现得狂热的倾向。你是说罗伯特·摩尔？罗伯特·摩尔。
Yeah, I thought you might talk about Tom Moore. Oh, no, no. Robert Moore would talk about I thought you might talk about Tom Moore. Tom Moore's different. Robert Moore would talk about the shadow like he was an evangelical pastor sometimes. And you know that poor Robert Moore's life ended very tragically. Well, it's funny because I didn't know that when I was reading him, but it was scaring me because he's so gentle and kind. And then he would start talking about, no, but the shadow is 100% evil and black, and if you take a step in there, it will eat you alive, and you integrate it and it was like this is anti-yungian there's something in you that is very dark and very scary and then
是的，我以为你会谈论汤姆·摩尔。哦，不，不。罗伯特·摩尔会谈论……我以为你会谈论汤姆·摩尔。汤姆·摩尔是不同的。罗伯特·摩尔有时会像福音派牧师一样谈论阴影。你知道可怜的罗伯特·摩尔的生活结局非常悲惨。嗯，这很有趣，因为我在读他的书时并不知道这一点，但这让我很害怕，因为他那么温柔和善良。然后他会开始谈论，不，阴影是100%邪恶和黑暗的，如果你踏进去一步，它会把你活活吃掉，然后你整合它，这感觉就像是反荣格的，你内心有一些非常黑暗和非常可怕的东西，然后
i was reading more about him and come to find out i mean there were medical things going on too but you know he does essentially shoot himself and his wife you know at the end of his life yeah it ended his life ended tragically in a suicide murder and um you know what does that say about jungian psychology you know it says how dangerous it is um robert moore i i loved his work but like you i sensed there was something unresolved in it uh he's stuff on the shadow wasn't good um it was like the satanic panic i mean it was wild and just so reactionary and against his against his whole persona i was shocked for years when i found that he'd shot himself in the head after shooting his wife. And it just left me speechless.
我读了更多关于他的资料，结果发现，我的意思是当时也有医疗方面的问题，但你知道，他本质上是在生命尽头开枪自杀了，还杀了他妻子，你知道。是的，他的生命以自杀谋杀悲剧性地结束了，嗯，你知道这说明了荣格心理学的什么？你知道，这说明它有多危险。嗯，罗伯特·摩尔，我喜欢他的作品，但像你一样，我感觉到其中有一些未解决的东西。嗯，他关于阴影的东西并不好，嗯，这就像撒旦恐慌，我的意思是，这太疯狂了，而且非常反动，违背了他……违背了他整个人格。多年来，当我发现他在枪杀妻子后对自己头部开枪时，我感到非常震惊。这让我哑口无言。
These people are supposed to be the guardians of our soul. But if there's things in us that we don't ever directly experience, you know, that we just described, you know, that comes out. And I think that's why psychology is changing and i think that i mean that's kind of the through line of this conversation you can do it in religion politics whatever but um you know you you feel when you read hillman that something's wrong you know that yeah and you feel when you read more that something's wrong you read james hollis and you feel like that person is a lot better actualized and okay.
这些人本应是我们灵魂的守护者。但如果我们内心有一些我们从未直接体验过的东西，你知道，我们刚刚描述的那些，你知道，它就会显露出来。我认为这就是心理学正在改变的原因，我认为，我的意思是，这算是这次谈话的主线，你可以在宗教、政治或其他任何领域这样做，但嗯，你知道，当你读希尔曼的书时，你会感觉到有什么不对劲，你知道，是的，当你读摩尔的书时，你会感觉到有什么不对劲。你读詹姆斯·霍利斯（James Hollis）的书，你会觉得那个人更加自我实现，而且很好。
I feel that James Hollis is quite integrated. Yeah, there's nothing in there that is a red flag. No, but there were red flags in Robert Moore and red flags in Hillman. And they start men's rights movements. All of those guys go kind of right wing and start these men's right movements at the end of their career. I don't know if you've read my essays on Hillman, have you or not? I read The Unmaking of a Psychologist and then I read all the people who were jumping off to critique that with their responses. I used to pay for the Wiley Library and I got so sick of dealing with the Wiley Library.
我觉得詹姆斯·霍利斯相当整合。是的，里面没有任何危险信号。不，但罗伯特·摩尔有危险信号，希尔曼也有危险信号。他们发起了男性权利运动。所有那些家伙在职业生涯结束时都变得有点右倾，并开始了这些男性权利运动。我不知道你是否读过我关于希尔曼的文章，你读过吗？我读了《心理学家的解构》，然后我读了所有那些跳出来用回应来批评它的人。我过去常付钱订阅威利图书馆（Wiley Library），我厌倦了处理威利图书馆的问题。
I would they would send me my login information six months later and I would be like well can I have six months free or refunded no you can't and that's just fine oh so over it well I can send anyone who's listening who wants them I can send them to you for free you know I have the pdf files but I basically said in those essays which by the way I published, I published in Britain, not in America, because I thought there were too many fans of Hillman in America who would object to what I had to say. He was so many Americans' first experience with Jung. You know, that was just the way they knew of it. But the father wound is huge in Hillman, and he enacted it with Jung. You know, he tried to basically say that he'd gone beyond Jung,
他们会在六个月后才把登录信息发给我，我会说，好吧，我能有六个月免费或退款吗？不，你不能，这没关系。哦，太受够了。好吧，我可以把这些发给任何想听的人，我可以免费发给你，你知道，我有PDF文件，但我基本上在那些文章中说——顺便说一句，我发表了，我在英国发表的，而不是在美国，因为我觉得美国有太多希尔曼的粉丝，他们会反对我的观点。他是许多美国人对荣格的初次体验。你知道，这就是他们了解荣格的方式。但父亲创伤在希尔曼身上非常巨大，他通过荣格将其表现了出来。你知道，他基本上试图说他已经超越了荣格，
he's better than Jung. But I think you nailed it earlier when you said that in his practice, Hillman was still Jungian. I once asked him at the end of a session, I said, Jim, everything that we've done is so Jungian. I'm waiting for the Hillman part. And he just looked at me and he said, I haven't yet developed a practice in line with my theory so that there was a big gap between his practice and his theory. You read him and he's telling everyone how post-Jungian he is, but being in analysis with him as I was,
他比荣格更好。但我认为你之前说得很对，当你说在实践中，希尔曼仍然是荣格派的。我曾经在一次咨询结束时问他，我说，吉姆，我们所做的一切都太荣格派了。我在等待希尔曼的部分。他只是看着我说，我还没有发展出与我的理论相一致的实践，所以他的实践和理论之间存在巨大的鸿沟。你读他的书，他告诉每个人他是多么后荣格派，但像我一样接受他的分析，
he was unbelievably orthodox Jungian. I couldn't even tell one bit of the analysis that wasn't purely jungian i heard him yelling about how jungianism resolves you know removes the symbol by analyzing it and you have to go into the symbol and i heard him yelling about archetypal psychology i never heard a case study of him practicing it that i can find anywhere no he didn't he doesn't have even one case study in all of his 24 books, which tells you something, doesn't it? I mean, Jung's work is full of case studies. When you start trying to give other people the medicine you need, you're saying that other people need to have a direct experience. It's one that you haven't had.
他简直是不可思议的传统荣格派。我甚至说不出分析中有哪一点不是纯粹荣格派的。我听他大喊大叫说荣格主义通过分析消除了象征，你必须进入象征，我听他大喊大叫关于原型心理学，我从未找到任何他实践它的案例研究。不，他没有，他在他所有的24本书中甚至没有一个案例研究，这说明了一些问题，不是吗？我的意思是，荣格的作品充满了案例研究。当你开始试图给别人你所需要的药物时，你是在说别人需要有直接的体验。那是一种你还没有过的体验。
And I think he wanted some kind of ego dissolving spiritual transcendental moment that he never he never was able to find or go into he did he did toward the end was aware of what he was missing in fact the red book maybe was that experience for him yes yes very good point the red book but also there's a book called archetypal process i don't know if you've seen it yeah that's one that is on my ebay alerts but it's very expensive so yeah just like your rootlage books if somebody sells one use and they don't know what it's worth i'll buy it but i don't have the money right now it's called archetypal, it was edited by David Ray Griffin. The subtitle of Archetypal Process is Jung, Whitehead and Hillman. And Hillman writes some fascinating stuff in there.
我认为他想要某种自我消解的、精神上的、超越性的时刻，但他从未……他从未能够找到或进入。他确实……他确实在最后意识到他缺少什么，事实上《红书》对他来说可能就是那种体验。是的，是的，很好的观点，《红书》，但还有一本书叫《原型过程》，我不知道你有没有见过。是的，那是我eBay提醒中的一本，但它非常贵，所以是的，就像你的劳特利奇（Routledge）书籍一样，如果有人卖二手书而他们不知道它的价值，我会买，但我现在没有钱。它叫《原型过程》，由大卫·雷·格里芬（David Ray Griffin）编辑。《原型过程》的副标题是《荣格、怀特海和希尔曼》。希尔曼在里面写了一些迷人的东西。
And he admits that his work is missing a whole dimension, which is the metaphysical, the spiritual dimension. He was longing for so much that he almost was trying to like resurrect paganism or something, you know. Exactly. He was trying to resurrect paganism. He hated Christianity, partly because he was Jewish, but he also hated Judaism. He did not like monotheism. He wanted the divine to be broken up into. He didn't like any form of monotheism,
他承认他的作品缺少一个维度，即形而上学的、精神的维度。他渴望得如此之深，以至于他几乎试图复兴异教或类似的东西，你知道。完全正确。他试图复兴异教。他讨厌基督教，部分因为他是犹太人，但他同时也讨厌犹太教。他不喜欢一神论。他想让神性被打破……他不喜欢任何形式的一神论，
whether his own Judaism or Christianity, and he didn't like Islam either. So he wanted us to go back to the Greek pantheon, the polytheism of the Greeks. I think he would have gone even farther back he wanted us to go back to the mother cult you know to the the venus uh figurines of the of the stone age i don't know if you can hear the torrential rain pounding on my roof here i'm not able to to. Yeah, that's good. So anyway, I think when I was studying with Hillman and being analyzed by him, there's a fellow called Ralph Maud came down from Alberta, Canada. And he asked Hillman a question, which I thought was
无论是他自己的犹太教还是基督教，他也不喜欢伊斯兰教。所以他想让我们回到希腊万神殿，回到希腊人的多神教。我认为他甚至想回到更早以前，他想让我们回到母系崇拜，你知道，回到石器时代的维纳斯小雕像。我不知道你能不能听到我屋顶上倾盆大雨的声音，我不能……是的，那很好。所以无论如何，我想当我和希尔曼一起学习并接受他的分析时，有一个叫拉尔夫·莫德（Ralph Maud）的人从加拿大阿尔伯塔省下来。他问了希尔曼一个问题，我认为这
completely spot on. He said, how come your work is asking us to go back to the religion of the ancient Greeks before Christianity? You're asking us to basically worship people like Athena and Artemis and Aphrodite. They're all, of course, the female goddesses. He wasn't terribly interested in the male gods except for Hermes I really do think he wanted to go back to the Venus of Willendorf and crawl into a cave of the Great Mother
完全切中要害。他说，为什么你的作品要求我们回到基督教之前的古希腊宗教？你基本上要求我们崇拜像雅典娜、阿耳忒弥斯和阿佛洛狄忒这样的人。当然，她们都是女性女神。他对男性神灵不太感兴趣，除了赫尔墨斯。我真的认为他想回到威伦多夫的维纳斯（Venus of Willendorf），爬进伟大母亲的洞穴里。
and anyway this guy from Alberta said why should we go back to the Greek religion when even the Greeks got rid of their own polytheism in favour of Christianity? Because the Greeks were one of the first cultures of the world to convert to Christianity. And he says to Hillman, why did the Greeks lose faith and belief in their own religions, their own many polytheisms? And Hillman couldn't answer it.
无论如何，这个来自阿尔伯塔的人说，为什么我们要回到希腊宗教，当希腊人自己都为了基督教而抛弃了他们自己的多神教时？因为希腊人是世界上最早皈依基督教的文化之一。他问希尔曼，为什么希腊人失去了对他们自己宗教、他们自己的多种多神教的信仰和信念？希尔曼无法回答。
So he was just silent. It's a great question. And that didn't happen often with Hillman when he was asked a question. He basically had nothing to say. And I suppose the visitor from Canada basically thought to himself, touche, you know, checkmate. Have you read the Willamette for the Dead that Hellman and Sanu Samshadani wrote? Yes, I reviewed that for a British journal. Oh, I didn't know that you had written a review of it.
所以他只是沉默了。这是一个伟大的问题。这在希尔曼身上并不常发生，当他被问到一个问题时。他基本上无话可说。我想那个来自加拿大的访客基本上心想，触碰到了（touche），你知道，将死。你读过希尔曼和索努·沙姆达萨尼（Sonu Shamdasani）写的《死者之书》（The Lament for the Dead）吗？是的，我为一家英国期刊写过书评。哦，我不知道你写过书评。
I have to look that up. I was impressed. I mean, I'm not wild. I mean, it seemed to be, especially in the beginning, some of the best writing that Hillman did. It's thoughtful and there's a depth to it. I liked it. Yeah, me too.
我得查查。我印象深刻。我的意思是，我并不疯狂。我的意思是，这似乎是，特别是在开头，希尔曼写得最好的一些东西。它很深思熟虑，而且有深度。我喜欢它。是的，我也是。
I liked it as well. And I like anything that Sonu Shamdasani does. I think he's a very balanced. One of the good things about Sonu Shamdasani is that he's a scholar. He's not a clinician. He's an historian of Jung's ideas. And he knows the whole context in which it all occurs and naturally he's of course the editor of the Red Book as well.
我也喜欢它。而且我喜欢索努·沙姆达萨尼所做的一切。我认为他非常平衡。索努·沙姆达萨尼的好处之一是他是一位学者。他不是临床医生。他是荣格思想的历史学家。他了解这一切发生的所有背景，当然，他也是《红书》的编辑。
He kind of is the reason it was published too. I mean you have Richard Knoll who's attacking Jung so maybe that motivates the family to want to defend him but I mean my understanding was Sanu basically got these copies of where Jung had mailed the Red Book to defend him but i mean my understanding was sonny basically got these copies of where yun had mailed the red book to the publisher but it was not a complete draft and said unless you let me publish the big one i'm going to publish the imperfect one and then the family gave him permission that's right but actually coming back to the red book i think what we can see there is the direct experience of the the god or the gods or the numina or whatever you want to call it. I don't really care.
他某种程度上也是它得以出版的原因。我的意思是，你有理查德·诺尔（Richard Knoll）在攻击荣格，所以也许这激励了家人想要保护他，但我的理解是，索努基本上得到了这些荣格寄给出版商的《红书》副本，但那不是完整的草稿，他说除非你让我出版大的那本，否则我就出版不完整的那本，然后家人给了他许可。那是对的，但实际上回到《红书》，我认为我们在那里可以看到对神、诸神或灵体（numina）或任何你想称呼它的东西的直接体验。我真的不在乎。
I'm not attached to a particular language is very disruptive. I mean, Jung's Red Book is basically an analysis of his own psychosis. Yeah, I think he could not find an analyst for him and he tried to basically become that no he tried to analyze himself through his own psychosis and i think it's rather coy and shy of the unions to constantly refer to this phase of his life as his creative encounter with the unconscious you know anyone with half an inkling about psychiatry can see that jung was struggling with a full-blown psychosis and even there's a debate about how much of it was a loss of control and how much was active imagination and you know
我不执着于特定的语言，它是非常具有破坏性的。我的意思是，荣格的《红书》基本上是他自己精神病的分析。是的，我认为他找不到分析师，他试图基本上成为那个……不，他试图通过他自己的精神病来分析自己，我认为荣格派不断地将他生命中的这个阶段称为他与无意识的创造性邂逅，这相当做作和害羞，你知道，任何对精神病学有一点了解的人都能看出荣格当时正在与全面的精神病作斗争，甚至关于其中有多少是失去控制，有多少是主动想象，还有你知道
what mindset is he in when he's doing this because he was seeing patients i mean he was punching the clock he's peeling the meat off his soul to patients. I mean, he was punching the clock. He's peeling the meat off his soul to talk directly to God and then clocking out and going to the hospital. Don't forget what I said to you about China. I think Jung was a good example of China. His persona was still intact. He was still acting as a respectable psychiatrist with his patients,
他在做这件事时处于什么心态，因为他当时还在看病人，我的意思是他在打卡上班，他把灵魂的肉剥下来给病人看。我的意思是，他在打卡上班。他剥下灵魂的肉去直接与上帝交谈，然后下班去医院。别忘了我跟你说的关于中国的事。我认为荣格是中国的一个好例子。他的人格面具（persona）仍然完好无损。他仍然作为一名受人尊敬的精神科医生与病人相处，
but within himself he was a seeding cauldron of psychotic activity, like he's a volcano that had exploded. But he knew it. He wanted to make it conscious and go all the way to the bottom. Yeah, he did, and he went all the way to the bottom. He does say in some of his essays that the psyche is like a volcano which can blow its top at any moment. Well, of course.
但在他内心深处，他是一个精神病活动的沸腾大锅，就像一座火山爆发了。但他知道。他想让它变得有意识，并一直走到最底层。是的，他做到了，他一直走到了最底层。他在他的一些文章中确实说过，心灵就像一座火山，随时可能爆发。嗯，当然。
And it's in all of us. It's in all of us whether or not we pretend that it isn't there or wish it away or try and cling to the ego. Yeah, he experienced that partly. It's a father wound. Talk about coming back to the father wound. I mean, Jung was terribly wounded by his father, you know, because Jung wanted to help his father understand the interior dimension
它在我们所有人身上。它在我们所有人身上，无论我们是否假装它不存在，或者希望它消失，或者试图紧紧抓住自我。是的，他部分地体验到了这一点。这是一种父亲创伤。谈谈回到父亲创伤。我的意思是，荣格被他的父亲深深伤害了，你知道，因为荣格想帮助他的父亲理解基督教的内在维度，
of Christianity, but his father wasn't interested in any interior dimension. He basically thought his son was mad. And he had lost his own faith that his father had. So he was refusing the pathway that was being offered to him to try and reconcile some of his persona. I think it's a classic case of healing the Oedipal complex. You know, Jung had outdone his father, but he didn't want to destroy his father like Oedipus did.
但他的父亲对任何内在维度都不感兴趣。他基本上认为他的儿子疯了。而且他失去了他父亲所拥有的信仰。所以他拒绝了提供给他的途径，试图调和他的一些人格面具。我认为这是一个治愈俄狄浦斯情结的经典案例。你知道，荣格超越了他的父亲，但他不想像俄狄浦斯那样摧毁他的父亲。
He wanted to remake his father. He wanted to redeem his father but he wanted he didn't want to destroy his father like Oedipus did he wanted to remake his father he wanted to redeem his father and of course then the whole thing gets acted out with Freud Freud was and Meyer and then Meyer through Hillman you know and then it's to a certain extent you I would be fascinated to know how much a father came plot can't the father complex came up and what hillman was telling you about your analysis yeah well my it won't surprise you to learn that my analysis was about my father wound yeah we give other people the medicine that we need you know we don't want to take i mean i have had a very big father wound. And I confronted up to Hillman one day. I just said, guess what, Jim? I said, what's happening? I said, my father has decided to come over here and meet you
他想重塑他的父亲。他想救赎他的父亲，但他不想像俄狄浦斯那样摧毁他的父亲，他想重塑他的父亲，他想救赎他的父亲，当然，整件事后来在弗洛伊德身上上演了，弗洛伊德是……还有迈耶（Meyer），然后迈耶通过希尔曼，你知道，然后在某种程度上，我非常着迷于想知道父亲情结在希尔曼告诉你关于你的分析时出现了多少。是的，好吧，我的……知道我的分析是关于我的父亲创伤，你不会感到惊讶。是的，我们给别人他们需要的药物，你知道，我们不想接受……我的意思是，我有一个非常大的父亲创伤。有一天我面对希尔曼。我只是说，猜猜怎么着，吉姆？我说，发生了什么？我说，我父亲决定过来见你，
and talk with me about my analysis. Hillman said, oh, oh, oh, this is getting close. He wasn't so brave anymore. My father just, you know, this is where synchronicity hits the road, you know, the rubber hits the road. I was working on my father complex and my father felt it. It doesn't matter that I was in America and he was 12,000 miles away in Australia. He felt it in the psyche.
并和我谈谈我的分析。希尔曼说，哦，哦，哦，这太接近了。他不再那么勇敢了。我父亲只是，你知道，这就是共时性（synchronicity）发挥作用的地方，你知道，橡胶撞击路面的地方。我正在处理我的父亲情结，我父亲感觉到了。我身在美国，而他在12000英里外的澳大利亚，这并不重要。他在心灵中感觉到了。
It could be through a small gap of communication and inflection of tone. I mean, so much of what we're aware of is not what we're aware of. So coming back to Jung, his break, his split with Freud really totally fragmented him. And a psychosis resulted with Jungians pretend to domesticate at some point. Well, that's what I wanted to ask you about is you don't like the Red Book, whereas I do, most Jungians do. I agree with you that most people, most most they sanitize it and they act like oh he made this beautiful work of art isn't his diary cool doesn't it look alchemical and it was like no this is a deep and profound suffering that is partially reconciled because it is
这可以通过微小的沟通差距和语调的转折来实现。我的意思是，我们所意识到的很多东西并不是我们所意识到的。所以回到荣格，他的决裂，他与弗洛伊德的分裂确实完全让他支离破碎。精神病导致了荣格派在某种程度上试图将其驯化。好吧，这就是我想问你的，你不喜欢《红书》，而我喜欢，大多数荣格派都喜欢。我同意你的观点，大多数人，大多数……他们美化它，表现得好像“哦，他创作了这件美丽的艺术品，他的日记不是很酷吗？看起来不是很炼金术吗？”而事实是，不，这是一种深刻而深远的痛苦，它被部分调和了，因为它是
an unreconcilable pain you know that he's going into and pain huge pain but you think that it hits him trying to be too prophetic or you don't like the presentation of the tone in the book, the persona of the author. I don't like the tone of the book. I was asked to write on it by Murray Stein in Zurich, and I did. But I told Murray, Murray, I don't like the Red Book. I think it's psychotic.
一种无法调和的痛苦，你知道，他正在进入其中，痛苦，巨大的痛苦，但你认为它让他试图变得太有预言性，或者你不喜欢书中呈现的语调，作者的人格面具。我不喜欢这本书的语调。苏黎世的默里·斯坦（Murray Stein）曾要求我写关于它的文章，我写了。但我告诉默里，默里，我不喜欢《红书》。我认为它是精神病性的。
I think that the prophetic tone is too strong. I find it too strident. You know, chapters called Things Which Are To Come or Things Which Have Yet To Come. Or Seven Sermons to the Dead. It's written in the tone of the Bible almost. Well, it's like people scraping their fingernails down a blackboard or something it just got on my nerves and well if he was coming down the mountain with it to bring
我认为预言性的语调太强烈了。我觉得它太刺耳了。你知道，章节叫《将要发生的事情》或《尚未发生的事情》。或者《死者的七次布道》。它几乎是用圣经的语调写的。嗯，这就像人们用指甲在黑板上刮一样，或者类似的东西，它只是让我心烦，好吧，如果他带着它下山带给大众，并开始一个邪教，把自己当作先知，你知道，制作乔丹·彼得森（Jordan Peterson）类型的YouTube视频，我认为那会是一个问题，但这是他在私下里咀嚼的东西，你知道，我觉得我通过艺术和写作私下咀嚼东西，坦率地说，它看起来并不那么好。我认为荣格完全有权做《红书》来拯救自己免于精神分裂症，但我不知道我们是否有权阅读它。你认为他会出版它吗？不。它确实在某个时候送到了出版商那里。他考虑过。
it to the masses and starting a cult and treating himself like the prophet and and you know making jordan peterson type youtube videos i think that would be a problem but it was something he chewed on privately which you know i feel like i chew on things privately through art and writing and it doesn't look that good frankly i i think jung had every right to do the red book to save himself from schizophrenia basically but i don't know if we have a right to read it do you you think he would have published it? No. It did go to publishers at one point. He thought about it.
是的，但我认为，我认为他更好的头脑会说服他不要出版它。而且博林根（Bollingen）有一些房间，家人仍然在守护。没人知道里面有什么。没人知道那些画。他的自传中有整整几章仍然没有出版，因为它们是丑闻。我曾经坐在苏黎世的一个棺材上，拥有这些房产的人进来了。
Yeah, but I don't think, I think his better mind would have convinced him not to get it published. And there's rooms in Bollingen that the family is still guarding. No one knows what's in there. No one knows the paintings. There are whole chapters of his autobiography that still haven't been published because they're scandalous. I was sitting on a casket once in Zurich, and the fellow who owned the premises came in.
他说，你知道你坐在什么上面吗？我说，不知道。他说里面有三章来自《回忆、梦、反思》，家人拒绝允许出版。其中一章是关于他与妻子的婚姻。另一章是关于他与情妇托尼·沃尔夫（Tony Wolfe）的终身恋情，家人不希望这些公开。他们有协议吗？
He said, do you know what you're sitting on? I said, no. He said there are three chapters in there from memories, dreams, reflections that the family has refused to allow to be published. One of the chapters was on his marriage to his wife. Another chapter was on his lifelong affair with his mistress, Tony Wolfe, which the family didn't want to become public. Did they have an arrangement?
我的意思是，她在某个时候和艾玛（Emma）一起旅行，所以，我的意思是，我们可以假设是有的。他们有协议，但今天的女权主义者会说，为你喝彩，你知道，你那该死的协议，你知道。为什么你的妻子没有情人？荣格基本上说，我需要我的情人，因为她是我的阿尼玛。嗯，今天那根本行不通。嗯，有些地方他非常保守，你知道，就像你在《如何阅读荣格》一书中提到的，他关于阿尼玛和阿尼姆斯以及他自己的
I mean, she was traveling with him and Emma at some point, so, I mean, we could hypothesize it was. They had an arrangement, but feminists today would say, bully for you, you know, your bloody arrangement, you know. Why didn't your wife have a lover? Jung basically said, I need my lover because she is my anima well today that just wouldn't wash well there are places where he's strangely conservative you know like you bring up in um the how to read yung book that his theories about anima and anima and his own
写作，为一种性心理学和政治铺平了道路，他说那是不对的，但他正在打开那扇门。他所说的话的含义是，你知道，这是我们的一部分。而且我的意思是，或者，你知道，我认为他们在《死者之书》中也谈到了这一点，
writing paved the way for a sexual psychology and politics that he says is not right, but he's opening the door to that. And the implications of what he is saying is that, you know, this is part of us. And I mean, or, you know, and I think they talk about it in the low amount for the dead too,
但有些地方他想要下降，然后回归。他不希望任何人只是下降到事物中。所以当现代主义者或超验主义者走得太远进入他们的抽象艺术时，他讨厌它，他希望他们去那里，感受它，然后回来，把它带入自我的世界，这是（你知道，那是一种保守的立场，你知道，不是政治上的，但非常保守）。所以荣格是一个矛盾的集合体，你知道，所以他给了我们进入心灵双性恋研究的入口，谈论男性的阿尼玛和女性的阿尼姆斯。嗯，詹姆斯·希尔曼把那一切都抛到了九霄云外，当他说如果阿尼玛是一个原型，
but there's places where he wants the descent and then the return. He doesn't want anyone to just descend into things. So when the modernist or the transcendentalists go way far into their abstract art he hates it he wants them to go there feel that and then come back and bring it into the world of the ego which is you know that's kind of a conservative position you know not politically but very conservative so jung was a bag of contradictions you know so he he gave us the the entrance into the study of bisexuality in the psyche talking about the anima in men and the animus in women um james hillman blew that out of the water when he said if the anima is an archetype
为什么它应该局限于男性？如果阿尼姆斯是一个原型，为什么它应该局限于女性？所以希尔曼谈到了男性和女性的阿尼玛和阿尼姆斯，顺便说一句，这是希尔曼真正成为后荣格派的方式之一，因为荣格派不认同那个理论。但希尔曼利用荣格的逻辑来反对他自己的论点。我同意希尔曼的观点。我认为那是一个进步。但如果你读荣格那篇叫《欧洲的女性》的文章，它谈到了女性日益男性化，
why should it be limited to men and if the animus is an archetype, why should it be limited to men? And if the animus is an archetype, why should it be limited to women? And so Hillman spoke about anima and animus in men and women, which is one of the ways, by the way, that Hillman was genuinely post-Jungian, because Jungians don't subscribe to that theory. But Hillman used Jung's logic against his own argument. And I agreed with Hillman on that. I thought that was a bit of an advance. But if you read Jung's essay called Women in Europe, which talks about the increasing masculinisation of women,
他早在20年代就能看出女性正在变得更加男性化。她们变得更像男人了。在我的国家，我相信在你的国家，女性现在要求有权从事男人从事的同样的运动。他在文化上也相对保守。我的意思是，有些地方以今天的标准来看，关于种族的话题绝对是有问题的，但他有一种态度，去印度冒险是可以的，去看瑜伽是可以的，但你不能做，你是白人，你不能那样做。我的意思是，我只是试图读他的书
and he could see right back in the 20s that women were becoming more masculine. They were becoming more like men. And in my country, and I'm sure in yours, women now demand the right to do the same sports that men do. He was relatively culturally conservative too. I mean, there's places that are definitely problematic by today's standards of what is what is okay to say about race but he had this attitude of it's okay to go adventure in india it's okay to go look at yoga but you don't do it you're white you can't do that i mean and i just i'm trying to read him
带着一些优雅，但那就在里面。它确实在里面。正如我之前所说，他的文章《欧洲的女性》以这句相当沉闷的句子结尾。他说，男人应该保持男人，女人应该保持女人。也许如果有脱口秀电台之类的东西，荣格可能就会成为他生命尽头的怪人。甚至坎贝尔（Campbell）也朝着那个方向发展。我的意思是，他死得相当早，
with some grace but that's in in there. It is in there. And just as I was saying before, his essay, Women in Europe, ends up with this rather deadening sentence. He said, men should remain men and women should remain women. And maybe if there had been a talk radio or something, it would have been Jung who became the crank at the end of his life. Even Campbell was kind of headed that way. I mean, he died pretty early,
但在他生命尽头有一些奇怪的谈话，他对着大学生大喊大叫关于马克思主义之类的东西。抱歉，我不是故意打断你的。不，不。所以我不知道荣格会对变性手术说什么。我怀疑他不会喜欢那样。不。当男人变成女人，女人变成男人，
but there's some bizarre talks at the end of his life where he's screaming at college students about being Marxist and stuff. Sorry, I didn't mean to cut you off there. No, no. So I don't know what Jung would have said about transsexual operations. I doubt he would have liked that. No. When men becoming women and women becoming men,
他会极其反对。他会说，如果你是一个男人，你认同你的女性一面，那么你的男性一面会发生什么？他会说它会落入无意识，变得被压抑，然后它会回来困扰你。嗯，但如果你不能保持你的阿尼玛，以至于你说你需要有一个后宫，因为它不适合你的妻子，那也许是，你知道，他身上也许发生了什么。嗯，他有一个镜子。甚至托尼·沃尔夫也无法处理炼金术。
he would have been outrageously against it. He would say that if you're a man and you identify with your feminine side, then what happens to your masculine side? He'd say it would fall into the unconscious, become repressed, and then it would come back and haunt you. Well, but if you're not able to hold your anima to the point where you're saying that you need to have a harem because it doesn't fit into your wife, that maybe is, you know, there's maybe something going on in him. Well, he had a mirror. Even Tony Wolfe couldn't deal with the alchemy.
我的意思是，她基本上离开了，因为他太沉迷于炼金术了。是的，是的，是的。不，托尼·沃尔夫当然遵循了他的类型理论。事实上，我认为是托尼·沃尔夫向荣格建议了类型理论，他采纳并发展了它，就像荣格有大恋情的另一个女人，来自俄罗斯的萨比娜·斯皮尔莱因（Sabina Spielrein）一样。有些人，就像他在书中写的，他们一起做音乐，或者疯狂，就像它是寓言一样。
I mean, she basically left because he got too into alchemy. Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, Tony Wolfe, of course, ran with his theory of types. In fact, I think it was Tony Wolfe who suggested the theory of types to Jung and he took it up and developed it, just as it was the other woman that Jung had a big affair with, Sabina Spielrein from Russia. Some people, like he wrote in the book that he had, they made music together or mad, like it was kind of allegorical.
你觉得那是一场性恋情吗？有分歧。不。你看过电影《危险方法》（A Dangerous Method）吗？我不知道我是否同意，我的意思是其中的SM部分或类似的东西，嗯，但我不知道什么是真的，什么是假的，除了知道电影中他和弗洛伊德之间的对话几乎是完全的交易，或者说它们就像他写的他们所拥有的完整转录，比如书架上的那个。那部电影的导演，那个加拿大人。是芬奇（Fincher）吗？
Do you feel like that was a sexual affair? There's disagreements. No. Have you seen the film a dangerous method i do i don't know that i agree with i mean the the snm part of it or whatever um but i don't know what's true and what's not true except it's important to know that the movie conversations between him and freud are almost complete transaction or like they're only they're like complete transcriptions of what he wrote that they had, like the wrap and the bookcase. The director of that film, that Canadian fellow. Is it Fincher?
芬奇，你认识他吗？我不记得是谁了，但他是一个弗洛伊德派。所以他有一个议程，那就是让荣格看起来很糟糕。他确实在《危险方法》中让荣格看起来很糟糕。他让荣格看起来像一个性野兽，在那些与萨比娜·斯皮尔莱因的场景中。但无论如何，我刚才的观点是，萨比娜·斯皮尔莱因，她对荣格说
Fincher, do you know him? I can't remember who it was, but he was a Freudian. So he had an agenda, which was to make Jung look bad. And he certainly did make Jung look bad in A Dangerous Method. And he made Jung look like a beast of sexuality with those scenes with Sabina Spielrein. But anyway, the point I was making was that Sabina Spielrein, who said to Jung
在他们性恋情期间的一次谈话中，她感觉到女性中有一种男性元素，男性中有一种女性元素。我不知道那些SM的东西是否真的发生了。那可能只是电影的一部分。但荣格说那是个好主意，他采纳了它并发展了他的反性（contrasexuality）理论。所以，你知道，荣格欠他周围女性很多，
that she felt there was a masculine element in women and a feminine element in men in a conversation during their sexual affair. I don't know if that S&M stuff happened at all. That could be just part of the movie. But Jung said that's a great idea and he ran with it and developed his theory of contrasexuality. So, you know, Jung owed a lot to the women around him
特别是托尼·沃尔夫和萨比娜·斯皮尔莱因。但他并不总是给予她们应得的认可。所以他是一个典型的父权制者，一个他那个时代的人。艾玛·荣格（Emma Jung）过着多么糟糕的生活啊，当他……她是那个为这一切买单的人，我的意思是，是她的时间救了他，是的，当他本不可能在没有我得到的资金的情况下探索这一切，因为那不是一个有利可图的努力。他非常有钱，是瑞士最富有的女性之一。他丢了工作。他不得不放弃他的工作，因为他快要精神失常了。
and worked with him, especially Tony Wolfe and Sabina Spiorine. But he didn't always give them the acknowledgement that they deserved. So he was a typical patriarch a man of his time and what kind of an appalling life did emma young have as he went she was the one that paid for all of it i mean it was her time bailed him out yeah when he couldn't have explored any of that without the funding that i got because it was not a profitable endeavor. He was very rich, one of the richest women in Switzerland. And he lost his job. He had to give up his job because he was going psychotic.
电影中我确实喜欢那个场景，弗洛伊德和荣格在船上要去不同的地方，弗洛伊德试图摆出父亲的姿态，对荣格拥有权威，然后荣格上楼，因为他的妻子为他预订了头等舱，而弗洛伊德下楼去……他……荣格有点说，哦，对不起，我妻子预订了票，我没做。这是一个很棒的场景，不是吗？是的，我确实喜欢那一刻，嗯，它相当感人，因为弗洛伊德是那个没有钱的人。
That scene in the movie I do love where Freud and Jung are going to the different places on the boat, and Freud is trying to have this father posture and have authority over Jung, and freud is trying to have this father posture and have authority over jung and then jung is going upstairs because his wife has booked him first class and freud is going down into the and he's and jung kind of says oh i'm sorry my wife booked the tickets i didn't do it it's a great scene isn't it yeah i love that moment actually uh it's quite moving because freud was the one without money.
而且他也是犹太人。我的意思是，他处理了很多反犹太主义。是的。而荣格有一笔财富。所以他不需要工作。他甚至不需要看病人，因为他们有足够的钱。他的经济状况非常稳固。然后，当然，在晚年，实际上是中年，
And he was Jewish too. I mean, he dealt with anti-Semitism a lot. Yeah. And Jung had a fortune. So he didn't need to work. He didn't even need to see patients because they had enough money. And his financial situation was very secure. And then, of course, late in life, midlife actually,
很多美国富人也来到瑞士资助他，比如梅隆家族（Mellons）。是的。而且，你知道，资助主要大学的梅隆家族，我想是耶鲁大学，并与普林斯顿大学出版社建立了博林根系列，他们支付了所有这些费用，以便荣格的德语著作都能被翻译成英语并在美国出版，他没有支付任何费用。这一切都是由他的恩人资助的。所以他在金钱方面过得很顺。这从来不是一个问题。不像我们大多数人。金钱是
a lot of American rich people came over to Switzerland to fund him as well, like the Mellons. Yeah. And, you know, the Mellons who had been funding major universities, I think it was Yale University, and set up the bollingen series with princeton university pres they paid for all of that so that jung's uh german uh writings could all be translated into english and published in in america that he didn't pay for any of that. It was all funded by his benefactors. So he had a dream run when it comes to money. It was never an issue. Not like most of us. Money is
一个大问题。对弗洛伊德来说也是如此。这就是主根疗法（taproot therapy）存在的原因。我们离开去开始这个，因为我厌倦了在病人没有保险时被迫把他们踢出去。我想能够……我记得希尔曼在德克萨斯州和我一起工作时告诉我的著名台词。他说，每个人都在担心如何终止分析。
a big issue. And it was for Freud as well. That's the reason taproot therapy existed. We left to start this because I was tired of being forced to kick patients out when they didn't have insurance. And I wanted to be able to... I can remember a famous line that Hillman told me while I was working with him in Texas. And he said, everybody's worried about how to terminate analysis.
移情（transference）什么时候结束？他对我说，房间里还有其他人，移情在客户没钱时结束。我不知道你是怎么负担得起七年或什么的分析，在你去苏黎世获得硕士学位以进行分析训练之前。我知道。也许这就是荣格主义作为一种纯粹实践正在消亡的原因之一。嗯，它太贵了。这就是它正在消亡的原因。但有些分析师有社会良知和浮动收费标准。所以如果你没有足够的
When does the transference end? And he said to me and there were others there in the room the transference ends when the client runs out of money i don't i i don't know how you afford to be in analysis for seven years or whatever before you go to zurich and get your you master's degree to get to analytical training. I know. Maybe that's one of the reasons that Jungianism is dying as a pure practice. Well, it's so expensive. That's why it's dying. But there are some analysts who have a social conscience and a sliding scale. So if you don't have enough
钱，一些分析师无论如何都会见你并少收你的钱，但嗯，希尔曼似乎没有浮动收费标准，我支付了标准费用。嗯，他知道他可以从送你过去的机构那里拿到钱，可能他知道我是由大钱资助的，他也想分一杯羹，正如他所做的那样，我不怨恨他，因为他给了我很多时间。我三年里每周见他两次，除了他在日本的时候。他总是要去日本。我不了解他生命中的那部分。
money, some analysts will see you anyway and charge you less but um hillman didn't seem to have a sliding scale i paid the standard fee well he knew that he could get the money out of the institute that was sending you over probably he he knew that i was being funded by big money and he wanted to share of that too as he did and i don't begrudge him that because he gave me a lot of time. I saw him twice a week for three years, except when he was in Japan. He was always heading off to Japan. I don't know that part of his life.
我想知道那里有什么让他感兴趣的。日本人对他那一套非常感兴趣，今天的日本荣格派深受希尔曼思想的影响。你知道建筑师莱昂·克里尔（Leon Krier），他做了英国庞德伯里（Poundbury），他是一位城市
I wonder what was interesting to him there. Japanese were very interested in his stuff and the Japanese Jungians today are very much shaped by Hillman's ideas. You know the architect Leon Creer who did Poundberry England and he's an urban
规划师，新城市主义者，但我们采访了他。莱昂·克里尔，他为英国查尔斯王子设计了庞德伯里镇。然后他在这里做了一些社区，像海滨瀑布（Seaside Falls）这样的新城市主义社区。哦，是的。
planner, new urbanist, but we interviewed him. Leon Creer, he designed the town Poundberry, England for Prince Charles in England. And then he did some like communities here, the New Orvinus communities like Seaside Falls. Oh, yeah.
他年纪大了。我们采访了他关于视觉原型和建筑的一些荣格应用。他见过希尔曼。他告诉我，希尔曼告诉他，当你去欧洲时，建筑，眼睛被向上拉，这样你就看着天堂，而当你去美国建筑时，有一个带荧光灯的吊顶，这样你就看着地狱，我觉得那很有趣。哦，亲爱的，但看，嗯，希尔曼在英国没有留下什么印象。
He's older. We interviewed him on this about some of the Jungian applications of visual archetypes and architecture. And he had met Hillman. And he told me that Hillman told him when you go to europe the the buildings the arc the eye is pulled up so that you look at heaven and when you go to an american building there's a drop ceiling with a fluorescent light so that you look at hell and i thought that was pretty funny oh dear but look um hellman hasn't made much impression in the United Kingdom.
他们不喜欢他。他们把他看作是一种骗子和自大狂。他太叛逆了。我的意思是，英国人喜欢某种权威或传统的东西，而他的东西是无缘无故地炸毁每一个传统。是的，完全正确。英国人不喜欢那样。至于澳大利亚，在这里，我的国家没有人听说过希尔曼。
They don't like him. They see him as a kind of a trickster and an egotistical maniac. He's too much of a rebel. I mean, the British like a kind of authoritarian or traditional thing, and his thing was to blow up every tradition for no reason. Yes, exactly. And the British don't like that. And as for Australia, here, no one in my country has ever heard of Hillman.
他们不喜欢他。他们把他看作是一个骗子和一个自大的疯子。他太叛逆了。我的意思是，英国人喜欢某种权威或传统的东西，而他的做法是无缘无故地炸毁每一个传统。是的，完全正确。英国人不喜欢那样。至于澳大利亚，在这里，我国家没人听说过希尔曼。
And they wonder why I spent so much time with him. Well, he was a major figure. And probably one of the first truly creative Jungians who reached out to a broader audience, particularly that book you mentioned. We've had a thousand years, or no, we've had a hundred years of psychotherapy and the world's getting worse. I didn't know, though, that he was on right-wing radio about that.
他们想知道为什么我花那么多时间和他在一起。嗯，他是个重要人物。而且可能是第一批真正有创造力的荣格学者之一，他接触到了更广泛的受众，特别是你提到的那本书。我们已经有了一千年，或者说，我们已经有一百年的心理治疗历史了，但世界却变得越来越糟。不过，我不知道他当时在右翼电台上谈论过那个话题。
Is that what you said? Yeah, so a lot of the talks that I have have i don't know when they were recorded i don't know what they are the recording quality is awful and they've been ripped from digital to they've been ripped from basically analog tapes so when i was getting into yung there was like a giant file that somebody had put up on the internet that you shared files on something called bit torrent at that point and so it's just terabytes and terabytes of Jungian talks and so I heard everything Moore, Hillman, Bly all these people said for their entire careers but so you heard it change too because you know they talked you know from the 70s until the 90s a lot of them
你是这么说的吗？是的，我有很多谈话录音，我不知道它们是什么时候录的，也不知道它们是什么，录音质量很差，它们基本上是从模拟磁带翻录成数字格式的。所以当我开始接触荣格时，网上有一个巨大的文件，是别人通过一种叫BitTorrent的文件共享方式分享的，里面有数TB的荣格讲座。所以我听过摩尔、希尔曼、布莱这些人整个职业生涯所说的一切。所以你也听到了他们的变化，因为你知道，他们从70年代一直谈到90年代，他们中的很多人。
Kohlschild and so but one of the appearances was Hillman on the radio kind of having this reactionary he was talking to I don't know the name of the program, but he was saying basically like, therapy is making us weak. We have to be tougher. And it was just the kind of reactionary stuff that seemed silly. Hillman went to a peace conference during the early 1980s in New York and gave this most crazy talk about the need for war and I said to him why did you do that for I mean you're trying hard to make yourself unpopular imagine going to a peace conference and talking
科尔希尔德（Kohlschild）等等，但其中一次露面是希尔曼在电台上表现出一种反动倾向。他当时在和——我不知道那个节目的名字——但他基本上是在说，治疗让我们变得软弱。我们必须更坚强。这只是一种看起来很愚蠢的反动言论。希尔曼在20世纪80年代初去纽约参加了一个和平会议，发表了一番关于战争必要性的疯狂言论。我对他说，你为什么要那样做？我的意思是，你是在努力让自己变得不受欢迎，想象一下去参加一个和平会议却在谈论
up war. He couldn't help it. It was this unconscious trickster and rebellious boy. He wanted somebody to put him in his place and tell him. Denis Levitov almost smashed him at that conference. I mean, she basically said, how dare you come here and talk about the virtues of war? And then he had the temerity to write a whole book on it called The Need for War or something. Do you know that book?
支持战争。他控制不住自己。这就是那个无意识的捣蛋鬼和叛逆男孩。他想让人把他放在他的位置上，教训他一顿。丹尼斯·莱维托夫（Denis Levitov）在那次会议上差点把他揍了一顿。我的意思是，她基本上说，你怎么敢来这里谈论战争的优点？然后他竟然有胆量写了一整本书，叫《战争的必要性》之类的。你知道那本书吗？
Is it The Glorious Love of War? That's a different author. Yes. Is that how it is? Yeah, The Glorious Love of War. I mean, what crazy crap was that all about you know i mean anyone with their right mind right i mean like i said you've got these youngians with this wound and the males they over identify with the anima in early life and then they get the only taste of
是《战争的光荣之爱》（The Glorious Love of War）吗？那是另一位作者写的。是的。是这样吗？是的，《战争的光荣之爱》。我的意思是，那到底是什么疯狂的垃圾？我的意思是，任何神志清醒的人，我的意思是，就像我说的，这些荣格学者带着这种创伤，男性在早年过度认同阿尼玛（anima），然后他们尝到了他们所拥有的唯一的
power that they've had and then they way over identify with the animus and they become, you know, dangerous. It's strange. Dangerous. I was totally against this bullshit about him praising war. And he said, don't worry, David, I have Mars accented strongly in my astrological chart. I said, I don't care what Mars is doing in your chart. I'm more interested in the well-being of the Earth and our future as a civilization.
权力，然后他们过度认同阿尼姆斯（animus），他们就变得，你知道，危险了。这很奇怪。危险。我完全反对他赞美战争的这种胡言乱语。他说，别担心，大卫，我的星盘里火星很强。我说，我不在乎火星在你的星盘里做什么。我更关心地球的福祉和我们作为文明的未来。
Yeah, in a time with nukes, you want to talk about, oh, well, Greeks went out in the phalanx and it made men, so we should extinct the planet with radiation. Freud used to complain that Jung was off with the fairies, but I tell you what, Hillman was off with the fairies as well. And this idea that we need to give Mars a prominent place. Well, I mean, the tradition of Western civilization has been one Mars catastrophe after another. The
是的，在有核武器的时代，你想谈论，哦，希腊人排成方阵出征，这造就了男人，所以我们应该用辐射让地球灭绝。弗洛伊德过去常抱怨荣格和仙女们混在一起，但我告诉你，希尔曼也和仙女们混在一起。这种我们需要给火星一个突出地位的想法。嗯，我的意思是，西方文明的传统就是一场又一场的火星灾难。
First World War, the Second World War, the Korean War. Hillman wasn't joining the army i mean he was telling other people to go to war he you know he wasn't signing up for a mercenary company he was sitting in an armchair you know he was in his chair writing about how great war i just said to him this is just bonkers this is crazy stuff um he said um i can't remember what he said but i was so appalled and then the next thing i heard it it linked up robert bly with a men's moon which of course attracted angry men angry young men and it needed help i mean the same thing you know a lot of those people that i mean because that's just those people are dime a dozen on youtube now now. You have to eat more red meat and women are trying to make you weak and all this stuff.
第一次世界大战，第二次世界大战，朝鲜战争。希尔曼并没有参军，我的意思是他在告诉别人去打仗，他并没有报名参加雇佣军公司，他坐在扶手椅上，你知道，他坐在椅子上写着战争有多伟大。我只是对他说，这简直是疯了，这是疯狂的东西。嗯，他说，嗯，我不记得他说了什么，但我感到非常震惊。接下来我听说它把罗伯特·布莱（Robert Bly）和男人的月亮联系在一起，这当然吸引了愤怒的男人，愤怒的年轻男人，它需要帮助。我的意思是同样的事情，你知道，那些人，我的意思是，因为那些人在YouTube上现在随处可见。你必须多吃红肉，女人正试图让你变得软弱，所有这些东西。
But they get you in the door with self-help. That's just cognitive psychology. It's not, you know, the tips work. But then the prescription after that is that you have to believe all this crazy stuff. I wrote a book denouncing Hillman and bly in regard to this stuff about men you mightn't have seen it but no one just the basic insecurity of it is so obvious i mean i was like i remember people saying stuff like that when i was 13 when i was an angry young man and i was just like no one would say this unless they were deeply insecure yeah but uh robert bligh hated that book i called it remaking men
但他们用自助心理学把你骗进门。那只是认知心理学。它不是，你知道，技巧是有用的。但随后的处方是你必须相信所有这些疯狂的东西。我写了一本书谴责希尔曼和布莱关于男人的这些东西，你可能没看过，但没有人，那种基本的不安全感太明显了。我的意思是，我记得当我13岁的时候，作为一个愤怒的年轻人，人们说过那样的话，我当时就想，除非他们内心极度不安，否则没人会这么说。是的，但是罗伯特·布莱讨厌那本书，我把它命名为《重塑男人》（Remaking Men）。
um i don't think it was even published in the states it was published in london i'd never heard of it no published in melbourne which is where i live and in london it sold quite well but i don't think it even touched ground on the u.s but ro Robert Bly read it, and he wrote me this furious letter about, you know, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. He was just so angry. And Hillman was angry too. And, in fact, at the end of his letter, Bly said, I'm going to tell Hillman about all this and blah, blah, blah.
嗯，我想它甚至没有在美国出版，它是在伦敦出版的。我从来没听说过。不，是在墨尔本出版的，那是我住的地方，在伦敦卖得相当好，但我觉得它甚至没在美国引起反响。但罗伯特·布莱读了它，他写了一封愤怒的信给我，关于，你知道，等等等等。他太生气了。希尔曼也很生气。事实上，在他信的结尾，布莱说，我要把这一切告诉希尔曼，等等等等。
Like he was your dad? Yeah. I'm going to tell your dad how naughty you've been i just imagining grown men you know saying so much he threatened yeah he said i'm gonna i said i'm writing this letter on a plane because i wanted it to be kept secret that's why i wrote it in a book and but anyway i i think that that beware the Jungians. I mean, some of them are brilliant. Tom Moore is brilliant and maintained his brilliance.
就像他是你爸爸一样？是的。我要告诉你爸爸你有多淘气。我只是想象成年男人，你知道，说这么多。他威胁说，是的，他说我要告诉他。我说我是在飞机上写这封信的，因为我想保密，这就是为什么我把它写在书里。但无论如何，我认为要提防荣格学者。我的意思是，他们中有些人很聪明。汤姆·摩尔（Tom Moore）很聪明，并且保持了他的才华。
And I think we can rely on James Hollis. And Robert Johnson's books are very good, although they're not intellectually oriented. And Robert Johnson's not so good on gender politics. I think he's very, very old fashioned about men and women and gender. The only person that Hellman even worked with for a while without fighting with them was Michael Mead. I mean, Michael Mead was the only person that he actually liked. But Michael Mead is so kind of out there and spacey
我认为我们可以信赖詹姆斯·霍利斯（James Hollis）。罗伯特·约翰逊（Robert Johnson）的书非常好，尽管它们不是以学术为导向的。罗伯特·约翰逊在性别政治方面不太好。我认为他在男人、女人和性别方面非常、非常老派。希尔曼唯一能共事一段时间而不吵架的人是迈克尔·米德（Michael Mead）。我的意思是，迈克尔·米德是他唯一真正喜欢的人。但迈克尔·米德太超脱、太飘了，
that I think they just didn't have enough of an ego to butt heads. But he basically fell out with everyone else. Because Michael Mead was just drumming and chanting, and so there was no ego to threaten Hillman's brilliance. I think Hillman and Tom Moore, I don't think they had a falling out, but I do think that they had some disagreements. I think basically on jealousy. Hillman was so jealous about Tom Moore's success.
以至于我觉得他们没有足够的自我去发生冲突。但他基本上和所有其他人都闹翻了。因为迈克尔·米德只是在打鼓和吟唱，所以没有自我去威胁希尔曼的才华。我认为希尔曼和汤姆·摩尔，我不认为他们闹翻了，但我确实认为他们有一些分歧。我认为基本上是因为嫉妒。希尔曼对汤姆·摩尔的成功非常嫉妒。
Was he of means? I mean, did he want more financial success? Yes. Hillman kept saying to me he had no superannuation and he wanted more money. And there's his student writing millions and millions of copies, Care of the Soul. I think good on Tom.
他是嫉妒财富吗？我的意思是，他想要更多的经济成功吗？是的。希尔曼一直对我说他没有养老金，他想要更多的钱。而他的学生写了数百万册的《灵魂的关怀》（Care of the Soul）。我认为汤姆做得很好。
I think he wrote some terrific stuff. But Hillman wrote basically as an intellectual for intellectuals. You know, you can't read Revisioning Psychology without having studied philosophy, psychology and sociology at university. It doesn't make sense. So Hillman was writing for highly educated people, whereas Tom Moore stepped down the ladder
我认为他写了一些很棒的东西。但希尔曼基本上是作为知识分子为知识分子写作的。你知道，如果不曾在大学学习过哲学、心理学和社会学，你就读不懂《重构心理学》（Revisioning Psychology）。它讲不通。所以希尔曼是为受过高等教育的人写作的，而汤姆·摩尔走下了阶梯，
and basically wrote for a much broader audience and hillman's eukens tend to know way too much i mean because it's like to make those connections you have to know sociology anthropology comparative religion you know ancient history and in order just to get your foot in the door and it's like who has all that that's right no nobody has all that so i mean to read hillman properly you need to be about 40 years old and have at least two or three degrees to make sense of it um that's why i think he he sold himself short when he teamed up with robert bligh you know you got the worst of hillman coming, and the best of Hillman was written in the 70s and 80s. And I think that none of the Hillman fans had the maturity or the education to actually understand early Hillman,
基本上为更广泛的受众写作。希尔曼的追随者往往知道得太多了，我的意思是，因为要建立这些联系，你必须了解社会学、人类学、比较宗教学、古代史，才能仅仅迈进门槛。这就像谁拥有所有这些？没错，没有人拥有所有这些。所以，要正确阅读希尔曼，你需要大约40岁，并且至少有两个或三个学位才能理解它。嗯，这就是为什么我认为当他和罗伯特·布莱合作时，他贬低了自己。你知道，你得到了希尔曼最糟糕的一面，而希尔曼最好的一面是在70年代和80年代写的。而且我认为没有一个希尔曼的粉丝有成熟度或教育背景来真正理解早期的希尔曼，
which was the main Hillman. Well, he started to try and write more broad mainstream, but when he got rid of it, he couldn't quite get rid of the intellectual bent and so it was just pretension there was there was no well one of his books became a bestseller i think it was code yeah yeah and i i think he got off on opera the opera show opera winfrey show oh yeah i didn't know he appeared on there and there there was his superannuation nest egg that he'd always wanted so he did um achieve a degree of popular success but i don't think the soul's code is a very interesting book you know it kind of fails conceptually um and it's mainly it's not
那才是主要的希尔曼。嗯，他开始尝试写更广泛的主流作品，但当他摆脱它时，他无法完全摆脱知识分子的倾向，所以那里只有矫揉造作。没有，嗯，他的一本书成了畅销书，我想是《灵魂密码》（The Soul's Code）。是的，是的，我想他在奥普拉·温弗瑞秀上火了。哦，是的，我不知道他出现在那里。那里有他一直想要的养老金储备。所以他确实取得了一定程度的流行成功，但我不认为《灵魂密码》是一本非常有趣的书。你知道，它在概念上有点失败，而且它主要不是
really a theory that i don't know i mean there's some interesting and poetic bits of it but it isn't no it's not as good as tom moore tom had the right recipe you know to go public as did robert johnson robert johnson's book sold in millions yeah you know his books he she we uh his other book called Ecstasy. There was another book by him called Inner Work for Harper Collins. Harper Collins made a fortune out of Robert Johnson. He's often not talked about. I think the envy toward Robert Johnson, who lived in San Diego, was so high that the Jungians couldn't stand even reading him well hillman was well known as a speaker and he was well known in different countries that kind of liked him but
一个真正的理论。我不知道，我的意思是，它有一些有趣和诗意的部分，但它不是，不，它不如汤姆·摩尔。汤姆有正确的配方，你知道，去大众化，罗伯特·约翰逊也是如此。罗伯特·约翰逊的书卖了数百万册。是的，你知道他的书《他、她、我们》（He, She, We），他另一本叫《狂喜》（Ecstasy）的书。他还有另一本叫《内在工作》（Inner Work）的书，是为哈珀柯林斯出版社写的。哈珀柯林斯从罗伯特·约翰逊那里赚了一大笔钱。他经常不被谈论。我认为对住在圣地亚哥的罗伯特·约翰逊的嫉妒太强烈了，以至于荣格学者们甚至无法忍受阅读他。嗯，希尔曼作为一名演讲者很出名，他在不同的国家也很出名，他们有点喜欢他，但是
so many unions around him were becoming rich i mean clarissa pinkola as does and these people they were just the 70s and 80s was like the union heyday and he could never really articulate what he was doing in a way that grabbed that zeitgeist in any kind of interesting way. Robert Bly made a fortune out of Jung, you know, writing that book Iron John based on Jungian reading of the fairy tale of Iron John. So a lot of people were making massive money. I mean, Josephbell made a fortune
他周围的许多荣格学者变得富有。我的意思是克拉丽莎·平科拉·埃斯特斯（Clarissa Pinkola Estés）等等，这些人，70年代和80年代就像是荣格学派的全盛时期，他从来没有真正以一种以任何有趣的方式抓住时代精神的方式表达他在做什么。罗伯特·布莱从荣格那里赚了一大笔钱，你知道，写了那本基于对《铁汉约翰》童话的荣格式解读的《铁汉约翰》（Iron John）。所以很多人赚了大钱。我的意思是，约瑟夫·坎贝尔（Joseph Campbell）赚了一大笔钱，
especially with the power of myth you know the tv series which was pure young but he didn't say it was and that's what annoyed me even his talks on schizophrenia and things like he's saying that and it's like this you're you're quoting case studies. You have to attribute this. So I don't think the Jungian heyday is over, by the way, Joel. I think we're going to get more and more of it. It's coming waves. The 80s was a wave, and the early 90s was a wave. You had, as you said, Clarissa Pinkola. I think right now is, too, with younger people.
特别是通过《神话的力量》（The Power of Myth），你知道，那个电视系列，那是纯粹的荣格学说，但他没说。这就是让我恼火的地方。甚至他关于精神分裂症之类的谈话，他都在说，这就像你在引用案例研究。你必须注明出处。所以我认为荣格学派的全盛时期并没有结束，乔尔。我认为我们会越来越多地看到它。它是一波接一波的。80年代是一波，90年代初是一波。正如你所说，你有克拉丽莎·平科拉。我认为现在也是，对于年轻人来说。
It's just that they don't have any money you know at least in the u.s like yeah we were opening taproot when i was meeting with the person who was helping you know and then there was a big wave with the red book there was a big wave with that um south korean boy band i mentioned bts the biggest selling album in the history of korea it's just going to go on and on because you're there's something vital in you that uh it has a future freud however is just going to get more and more looking passe out of date yeah i i don't i never or joseph campbell actually has a pretty good quote where he said you know i read jung and i read freud when i was younger and i thought they were both interesting and then i read jung and freud again five years later and i didn't get anything else out of jung out of freud
只是他们没钱，你知道，至少在美国是这样。是的，我们正在开设Taproot，当时我正在和帮助我的人会面。然后《红书》（The Red Book）掀起了一大波浪潮，那个我提到的韩国男团BTS也掀起了一大波浪潮，那是韩国历史上销量最高的专辑。它只会一直持续下去，因为你，你身上有一些至关重要的东西，它有一个未来。然而，弗洛伊德只会看起来越来越过时。是的，我从来没有，或者约瑟夫·坎贝尔实际上有一个很好的引语，他说，你知道，我年轻时读过荣格和弗洛伊德，我觉得他们都很有趣。然后五年后我又读了荣格和弗洛伊德，我从荣格那里没得到什么，从弗洛伊德那里也没得到什么，
but jung got hit different and then i read him again five years later and i got something else out of the same jung but i didn't get anything out of freud and finally i just quit rereading freud and only read Jung. It does grow with you over your life in a way that Freud is kind of a one-note. I still read Freud because he's such a great writer. He writes in a beautiful, succinct style. He was. Well, there's just an efficiency to the way he presents information. Yeah, I love the way he presents his ideas, even though I disagree with most of them.
但荣格给我的感觉不同。然后五年后我又读了他，我从同一个荣格那里得到了别的东西，但我从弗洛伊德那里什么也没得到。最后我干脆放弃重读弗洛伊德，只读荣格。它确实随着你的一生而成长，而弗洛伊德有点单调。我仍然读弗洛伊德，因为他是一位伟大的作家。他以一种优美、简洁的风格写作。他确实是。嗯，他呈现信息的方式有一种效率。是的，我喜欢他呈现观点的方式，尽管我不同意其中的大部分。
But I still admire Freud as a stylist. I admire Hillman as a stylist and don't always agree with him either. And I tried to reread Hillman's Revisioning Psychology a couple of years ago. It was like grating on me a bit. You know, he was too too flashy he was trying to sort of flash his his credentials around i think he wrote that book in order to get a top-notch job in a 90 league northeast american university but nobody took the bait he did deliver those lectures at Yale University for the Terry lectures. Jung delivered Terry lectures too, which were called Psychology and Religion.
但我仍然钦佩弗洛伊德作为文体家。我钦佩希尔曼作为文体家，也不总是同意他的观点。几年前我试着重读希尔曼的《重构心理学》。它让我有点刺耳。你知道，他太浮夸了，他试图炫耀他的资历。我想他写那本书是为了在东北部常春藤盟校得到一份顶级工作，但没人上钩。他确实在耶鲁大学发表了泰瑞讲座（Terry Lectures）。荣格也发表过泰瑞讲座，叫《心理学与宗教》。
And Hillman, I think there were too many intellectuals that worried about Hillman and worried about his flashy style and well i mean if you want to work in an institution you cannot be the rebel you know this the college does not make this person who wants to blow things up even if they're right you know i i worked in a hospital for a while and there's this attitude of well sarah has a good idea but tiffany has a phd and we sell phds here so do your time and then we'll listen to you i mean hillman eventually took a job at the university of dallas you know which is a catholic university i don't know what he was doing in a catholic university but it was and of course he got he ended up getting sacked yeah because he was a rebel and they didn't want him there the psychology department said you're not a psychologist and the philosophy probably would have agreed with that too
而希尔曼，我认为有太多的知识分子担心希尔曼，担心他浮夸的风格。嗯，我的意思是，如果你想在机构里工作，你不能成为叛逆者。你知道，大学不会录用这个想要炸毁一切的人，即使他们是对的。你知道，我在医院工作过一段时间，有一种态度是，嗯，莎拉有个好主意，但蒂芙尼有博士学位，我们这里卖的是博士学位，所以熬过你的时间，然后我们会听你的。我的意思是，希尔曼最终在达拉斯大学找到了一份工作，你知道，那是一所天主教大学。我不知道他在天主教大学做什么，但当然，他最终被解雇了，是的，因为他是个叛逆者，他们不想要他。心理学系说你不是心理学家，哲学系可能也会同意这一点。
i think he did agree yeah and he's the philosophy department said you're not a philosopher either you know and there was will you cross both of those worlds your career is english and anthropology and psychology and philosophy. Well, it's a bit like Jung. See, if you become too disciplinary, the university system doesn't like you because you don't fit anywhere. Jung didn't fit in psychology and he didn't fit in philosophy, nor did Hillman, nor did he fit anywhere.
我想他确实同意，是的。哲学系说你也不是哲学家。你知道，你跨越了这两个世界，你的职业是英语、人类学、心理学和哲学。嗯，这有点像荣格。你看，如果你变得太跨学科，大学系统就不喜欢你，因为你不适合任何地方。荣格不适合心理学，也不适合哲学，希尔曼也不适合，他哪里都不适合。
So the university these days just don't even bother with you or Hillman. I think I said it's something where if you become too multidisciplinary, the universities think you become undisciplined, literally undisciplined, and you're not following the code of any of the established disciplines. So Hillman was booted out of Dallas University. And by the time I worked with him, he and some of his friends in Texas had formed a new institute called the Dallas Institute of Humanities and Culture, which was formed by Robert Sardello.
所以现在的大学甚至不理会你或希尔曼。我想我说过，如果你变得太跨学科，大学认为你变得不守纪律，字面上是不守纪律，你没有遵循任何既定学科的准则。所以希尔曼被达拉斯大学踢了出来。到我与他共事时，他和他在德克萨斯的一些朋友成立了一个新研究所，叫达拉斯人文与文化研究所（Dallas Institute of Humanities and Culture），是由罗伯特·萨德洛（Robert Sardello）成立的。
Do you know his work? I'm not familiar. Yeah, I think he's written some very fine work in recent years. He's explored the relationship between Jung and Steiner, Rudolf Steiner. Of course, Gail Thomas and Louise and Donald Cowan from the University of Dallas all formed this Dallas Institute.
你知道他的作品吗？我不熟悉。是的，我认为他近年来写了一些非常好的作品。他探讨了荣格和施泰纳（鲁道夫·施泰纳）之间的关系。当然，盖尔·托马斯（Gail Thomas）和来自达拉斯大学的路易丝和唐纳德·考恩（Louise and Donald Cowan）都组成了这个达拉斯研究所。
And my sponsors from New York came down to check it out, but they weren't impressed. They just saw it as some sort of breakaway group that don't fit into the university system. They came down to the Dallas Institute and and they said to me we want you back up northeast and one guy looked at me and he said there's no good can come out of texas and i think he meant it you know a real new yorker and of course i don't know if he was quoting scripture but um you know in the new testament says no there can be no good come out of nazareth
我来自纽约的赞助人下来考察了一下，但他们印象不深。他们只是把它看作是一个不适合大学系统的分裂组织。他们来到达拉斯研究所，对我说，我们想让你回到东北部。一个人看着我说，德克萨斯州不会有什么好东西。我想他是认真的，你知道，一个真正的纽约人。当然，我不知道他是否在引用经文，但嗯，你知道，在新约中说，拿撒勒能出什么好东西吗？
um someone says i think it's someone called nathaniel in the bible i'm not sure if he was quoting or it was just a coincidence but the new york sponsors were not impressed by hillman or the dallas institute but But I fought against them. I said, I'm here and I'm staying here. And so, you know, I really enjoyed my time at the Dallas Institute. I loved my time with Hillman as my analyst. I thought it was fantastic. And he helped me through my father complex.
嗯，有人说，我想是圣经里一个叫拿但业的人。我不确定他是在引用还是纯属巧合，但纽约的赞助人对希尔曼或达拉斯研究所印象不深。但我反抗他们。我说，我在这里，我会留在这里。所以，你知道，我非常享受在达拉斯研究所的时光。我喜欢和希尔曼作为我的分析师在一起的时光。我觉得这太棒了。他帮助我克服了父亲情结。
That's priceless. Yeah. And I didn't even know I had a father complex. Was the analysis, you know, were you confronting things in a directly experiential way or was it a pretty intellectual kind of analysis? No, it was quite experiential. Well, that's good.
那是无价的。是的。我甚至不知道我有父亲情结。分析是，你知道，你是以一种直接的经验方式面对事情，还是这是一种相当知识分子式的分析？不，这是相当经验性的。嗯，那很好。
Maybe that's what he was trying to figure out a way to do. That's what Newman was good at. But unfortunately, none of that is translated into his writings. Yeah, that's what's missing. It's so strange. He's talking about direct experience, but then he wants to be a detached intellectual. And it's like, it doesn't work. Because in my experience with Jungian analysis it's like i know these complexes
也许这就是他试图找出一种方法去做的事情。那是纽曼（Newman）擅长的。但不幸的是，这些都没有转化为他的著作。是的，这就是缺失的东西。这太奇怪了。他在谈论直接经验，但他又想成为一个超然的知识分子。这就像，它行不通。因为在我的荣格分析经验中，就像我知道这些情结，
i can feel it and i'm analyzing it and they still have a hold on me you have to be pushed into going into the dark place and yes if he probably was effective at pushing i mean hillman was effective at pushing people yeah i think so i think hillman did a lot of good as an analyst, and I certainly have nothing but praise for him at that level. It's only his career that I'm critical of. I had one analyst. I had another analysis before I went to America with a woman, and that analysis was on my mother complex, and that was very successful.
我能感觉到它，我正在分析它，但它们仍然控制着我。你必须被推向黑暗的地方。是的，如果他可能在推动方面很有效，我的意思是希尔曼在推动人们方面很有效。是的，我想是的。我认为希尔曼作为分析师做了很多好事，我当然对他那个层面的工作只有赞美。我只是批评他的职业生涯。我有一位分析师。在去美国之前，我和一位女士进行了另一次分析，那次分析是关于我的母亲情结，非常成功。
But I still have a mother complex. I think these things, you don't get rid of them. I still have a father complex, even though I worked on it with Hillman. It's just that I know them better. It's not that I've got rid of them. I know them now. I know my father complex. I know my mother complex.
但我仍然有母亲情结。我认为这些东西，你无法摆脱它们。我仍然有父亲情结，尽管我和希尔曼一起处理过它。只是我更了解它们了。并不是说我已经摆脱了它们。我现在了解它们了。我知道我的父亲情结。我知道我的母亲情结。
They're friends of mine close friends and i draw from them and they draw from me too and make demands on me so i don't think this idea that you work on the unconscious in order to go to a higher or better place. I don't subscribe to that at all. I think you just go back to where you started and know the place for the first time, to quote T.S.L. The Fisher King, that you're going back to the same place you were as a child, but you're getting rid of it. I go back to where I began and know it for the first time. And that's got a lovely warm feeling to it.
它们是我的朋友，亲密的朋友，我从它们那里汲取力量，它们也从我这里汲取力量，并对我提出要求。所以我不同意这种为了去一个更高或更好的地方而处理无意识的想法。我根本不认同这一点。我认为你只是回到了你开始的地方，并第一次认识了这个地方，引用T.S.艾略特的话。渔王，你回到了你小时候所在的同一个地方，但你正在摆脱它。我回到我开始的地方，第一次认识了它。这有一种可爱而温暖的感觉。
And I thank Hillman for that. And I thank my first analyst, Janice Dorr, for that too. So I have enormous good feelings. And I'm still in analysis today with someone because he's so good with dreams. I'm not so good with my own dreams. Have you ever tried brain spotting? Have you ever heard of that? Who?
我感谢希尔曼。我也感谢我的第一位分析师，珍妮丝·多尔（Janice Dorr）。所以我有很多美好的感觉。我今天仍然在和某人进行分析，因为他非常擅长解梦。我不擅长解自己的梦。你试过脑点疗法（Brain spotting）吗？你听说过吗？谁？
Brain spotting. It's a newer brain-based medicine therapy technique. Oh, I've heard of them. Yes, yes, yes. I've heard of brain spotting, yeah. But no, I haven't. It's wildly psychedelic. You're just looking at a pointer.
脑点疗法。这是一种较新的基于大脑的医学治疗技术。哦，我听说过。是的，是的，是的。我听说过脑点疗法，是的。但我没有试过。它非常迷幻。你只是看着一个指针。
I mean, that's it. The person is looking at a spot where your eye dilates but um it digs up really amazingly profound dreams very quickly um you know if you're into dream work i'd recommend and it only takes you know 30 minutes to do it and you're done so i mean i would recommend finding somebody if you're interested in dream work because it's love to know your experience with it right i've been in every kind of therapy that exists or i mean of course not every kind but i don't think you get just get the training i think you actually have to be in it as a patient and jungian analysis is very different well that's the way jungian analysis works yeah and well i but that you know i was in analysis but i also did internal family systems i also did
我的意思是，就是这样。那个人看着一个点，你的眼睛会放大，但嗯，它能很快挖掘出非常令人惊叹的深刻梦境。嗯，你知道，如果你喜欢解梦，我会推荐它，而且只需要30分钟就能完成。所以，我的意思是，如果你对解梦感兴趣，我会建议找个人，因为我很想知道你的体验。没错，我尝试过现存的每一种疗法，或者我的意思是，当然不是每一种，但我不认为你只是接受培训，我认为你实际上必须作为病人参与其中，而荣格分析是非常不同的。嗯，这就是荣格分析的工作方式。是的，嗯，但我，你知道，我进行了分析，但我也做了内在家庭系统疗法（IFS），我也做了
cognitive behavioral therapy you know i did these things. And 40 minutes of brain spotting, my life was just different. I felt this awful physical feeling. And I realized I'd been trying to run from that and turn that off my whole life. And then just two or three days of wild emotional experiences and prophetic dreams. And it tends to be the experience patients have. I mean, it's growing. I think that's the future of a lot of trauma work. Wow, that's a very good wrap.
认知行为疗法（CBT），你知道，我做了这些事情。而40分钟的脑点疗法，我的生活就完全不同了。我感到一种可怕的身体感觉。我意识到我一生都在试图逃避那个并关闭它。然后仅仅两三天疯狂的情绪体验和预言性的梦。这往往是病人有的体验。我的意思是，它正在增长。我认为这是许多创伤工作的未来。哇，那是一个非常好的总结。
Yeah. I think we'd better finish up here. Sure, yeah. I don't want to take any more of your time, but it's fascinating. I'm very happy. You seem to know so much, as I keep saying. It's a great pleasure talking to you. Well, maybe the podcast is just kind of an ongoing thing,
是的。我想我们最好在这里结束。当然，是的。我不想再占用你的时间了，但这太迷人了。我很高兴。正如我一直说的，你似乎知道得太多了。和你谈话真是太愉快了。嗯，也许播客只是一种持续的事情，
so I'm sure we could talk again on another topic at some point. We've got a lot of stuff about Jung and architecture coming up. One of the British academic is doing a lot of work on Bollingen, so we're trying to find a time to connect. Different things about archetypal applications and architecture is kind of an interest of mine. Is that Lucy Huskinson? No, I emailed her, and then she said Martin Gledhill
所以我相信我们可以在某个时候就另一个话题再次交谈。我们有很多关于荣格和建筑的内容即将推出。一位英国学者正在对博林根（Bollingen）做大量研究，所以我们正在努力寻找时间联系。关于原型应用和建筑的不同事物是我的一种兴趣。那是露西·哈斯金森（Lucy Huskinson）吗？不，我给她发了电子邮件，然后她说马丁·格莱德希尔（Martin Gledhill）
was her friend that was doing it, and so I talked to him. I think his name is Martin Gledhill. I don't know if I'm saying that right. I've got two books by Lucy Huskinson on architecture and archetypes. She said she was working on Nietzsche now, so it wasn't a good time to talk about you. She's always working on Nietzsche. She did her PhD on Nietzsche as well.
是她的朋友，正在做这件事，所以我和他谈过了。我想他的名字是马丁·格莱德希尔。我不知道我读得对不对。我有两本露西·哈斯金森关于建筑和原型的书。她说她现在正在研究尼采，所以现在不是谈论荣格的好时机。她总是在研究尼采。她也做了关于尼采的博士学位。
But she's a very bright woman who lives in Wales and works at the University of North Wales there. And yeah, she does some great work in architecture. But I'm out of my depth with architecture. I can't speak about the topic. Well, yeah, my dad is is an architect so maybe that's a father complex oh well there you go i uh well it's funny the synchronicity like when i wrote i wrote this article on leon career's design and you know he's a big deal that's older and i'm writing on a therapy blog in birmingham alabama so it's like
但她是一位非常聪明的女性，住在威尔士，在北威尔士大学工作。是的，她在建筑方面做了一些很棒的工作。但我对建筑一窍不通。我无法谈论这个话题。嗯，是的，我爸爸是建筑师，所以也许那是父亲情结。哦，好吧，就是这样。嗯，这很有趣，同步性，就像我写了这篇关于莱昂·克里尔（Leon Krier）设计的文章，你知道，他是个大人物，年纪大了，我正在阿拉巴马州伯明翰的一个治疗博客上写文章，所以就像
you don't expect him to see it but i was writing in and then i was like well my dad's an architect and i'm writing about architecture but i'm a social worker so what if people see it and they're like you don't understand architecture good and so you know somebody might see it from think whatever and then leon here sent me an email and was like, this is great. Oh, that's nice. Yeah, that's great. Well, that's terrific. But you've obviously got a farther connection with architecture like I don't have yet.
你没指望他会看到它，但我当时在写，然后我就想，嗯，我爸爸是建筑师，我正在写关于建筑的文章，但我是一名社会工作者，所以如果人们看到它，他们会说你不懂建筑，那该怎么办？所以，你知道，有人可能会看到它，认为无论什么。然后莱昂·克里尔给我发了一封电子邮件，说，这太棒了。哦，那很好。是的，那太棒了。嗯，那太棒了。但你显然和建筑有父亲的联系，而我还没有。
So, yeah. What I usually do with the podcast is I put it out on YouTube and then I also put it out on our podcast, the audio of it. Is there anything that you want to promote or point people to go back to? I mean, you have a lot of books. Anything that you want to promote? I should have a website,
所以，是的。我通常在播客上做的是把它发布在YouTube上，然后我也把它发布在我们的播客上，它的音频。有什么你想推广或指引人们回去看的东西吗？我的意思是，你有很多书。有什么你想推广的吗？我应该有一个网站，
but I don't seem to have a website. I'm not too old-fashioned. But yeah, I've done 16 books on the topics that we're talking about. Some of them you've never heard of i can tell that doesn't matter i don't care but i buy them when i can find them but uh there's i've got a couple of years a very good self-promoter you know um i don't promote myself i just think that if people are ready to read my stuff they'll find it but you know i have a lot of it finds a new
但我似乎没有网站。我不太老派。但是的，我已经写了16本关于我们正在谈论的话题的书。其中一些你从来没听说过，我看得出来。那没关系，我不在乎，但当我能找到它们时我会买它们。但嗯，我有几年，非常好的自我推销者，你知道，嗯，我不推销自己，我只是认为如果人们准备好读我的东西，他们会找到它。但你知道，我有很多它在Audible上找到了新的
life on audible you know that people have these audio books and so somebody who wrote a book 10 20 years ago they do an audio version and then it sales explode so maybe investing in somebody to read them would uh would promote the sales someone kindly wrote me a wikipedia page so if you key in my name a wikipedia but it's not updated unfortunately it hasn't got all of my stuff in it the criticisms of james hillman on his page here mentioned on that wikipedia page too are they yeah on james hillman there's criticisms of him and you're i think they cite it probably is on making of a psychologist i'm not sure what they're citing all right okay some mentions there too i think it was a fellow from norway that did that page for me but i certainly wasn't me or someone that i know i just i'll look one day
生命，你知道，人们有这些有声读物，所以有人在10、20年前写了一本书，他们做了音频版本，然后销量爆炸。所以也许投资找人读它们会促进销售。有人好心地为我写了一个维基百科页面，所以如果你输入我的名字，有一个维基百科，但不幸的是它没有更新，它没有我所有的东西。詹姆斯·希尔曼页面上对他的批评在这里也提到了，在那个维基百科页面上，是吗？是的，在詹姆斯·希尔曼那里有对他的批评，我想他们引用了它，可能是在《心理学家的制造》（Making of a Psychologist）上，我不确定他们引用的是什么。好吧，好的，那里也有一些提及。我想是一个来自挪威的家伙为我做了那个页面，但我当然不是我，也不是我认识的人。我只是，有一天我会看。
no so there's a wikipedia page on it it's sort of like magic. But I don't have a website, as I said, which I should change. I should get into the 21st century. Sure. Well, if you need help, let me know. We built one for work. So it's fairly easy now to get a template and link to your books and different things. It's just kind of like making a Word document at this point.
不，所以上面有一个维基百科页面，它就像魔法一样。但我没有网站，正如我所说，我应该改变这一点。我应该进入21世纪。当然。好吧，如果你需要帮助，请告诉我。我们为工作建立了一个。所以现在获得一个模板并链接到你的书和不同的东西相当容易。在这一点上，它就像制作一个Word文档一样。
Anyway, it's been wonderful talking to you thank you so much for your time we ran over and i i appreciate you um making time to sit down with us because it i mean it is fascinating to hear directly from from you you know you read somebody's books you get a sense of who they are but then you still have questions about you know the the way that um you know details about things that you don't know until you ask. So it's fascinating, and I'm sure people will love to hear your insights into all these things. Thank you.
无论如何，和你谈话真是太棒了，非常感谢你的时间。我们超时了，我很感激你抽出时间坐下来和我们谈话，因为，我的意思是，直接从你那里听到这些真是太迷人了。你知道，你读某人的书，你会对他们是谁有一种感觉，但你仍然有关于，你知道，你知道的细节的问题，直到你问。所以这很迷人，我相信人们会喜欢听到你对所有这些事情的见解。谢谢。
Well, and as I said, I've lived in the States, so I have a taste about what America is like. I saw the good and I saw the bad. I was walking down Washington, one day and this guy came crashing out of this department store with stolen goods and then these police screaming stop or we'll shoot. You know I thought only in America could I see a scene like that you know and I was scared stiff because that doesn't happen in australia we're not gun we're not big on guns here at all you never hear people or police shooting people in australia it
嗯，正如我所说，我在美国住过，所以我对美国是什么样子有体会。我看到了好的一面，也看到了坏的一面。有一天我走在华盛顿，这个家伙带着赃物从百货商店冲出来，然后警察尖叫着停下，否则我们就开枪。你知道，我想只有在美国我才能看到那样的场景，你知道，我吓坏了，因为这在澳大利亚不会发生，我们这里根本不热衷于枪支，你永远不会听到人们或警察在澳大利亚开枪射击人，它
just doesn't happen um and they started firing at this guy and i i was i was just beside myself with terror and sorrow for this guy. I don't know what he stole, but it was certainly not worth him losing his life. You know, he might have stolen some sort of hi-fi or TV or something. But America scares me about the guns there, you know, all those guns. We don't have guns here. It's illegal to carry a gun in my country. But not in yours, I know. You know, it's very different.
根本不会发生。嗯，他们开始向这个家伙开火，我，我简直被对这个家伙的恐惧和悲伤淹没了。我不知道他偷了什么，但这肯定不值得他失去生命。你知道，他可能偷了某种音响或电视之类的东西。但美国关于那里的枪支让我害怕，你知道，所有的那些枪。我们这里没有枪。在我的国家携带枪支是非法的。但在你的国家不是，我知道。你知道，这非常不同。
The right of Americans to bear arms is in the Constitution. It is. It is a very different culture from a lot of the world, but I think that we've kicked the can down the road on a lot of problems for a long time that we can't kick it anymore. I mean, climate change is a whole other conversation, but, I mean, Australia is maybe the canary in the coal mine for the rest of the world.
美国人携带武器的权利在宪法中。确实。这是一种与世界许多地方非常不同的文化，但我认为我们在很多问题上拖延了很久，我们不能再拖延了。我的意思是，气候变化是另一个话题，但，我的意思是，澳大利亚可能是世界其他地方的煤矿里的金丝雀。
So there's things creating bigger problems there. I think the world is so tired of waking up and turning on the news and finding there's been yet another american massacre in a shopping center or a school or a movie house you know we're just so tired of it we don't not not to mention you people but we don't even see it anymore. I mean, I had people, patients were calling to be seen for a workplace shooting, and I didn't even hear about it. I didn't even know what it was.
所以那里有制造更大问题的事情。我认为世界已经厌倦了醒来，打开新闻，发现又发生了一起美国购物中心、学校或电影院的大屠杀。你知道，我们太累了，我们甚至不再关注了。我的意思是，我有病人打电话来咨询工作场所枪击事件，我甚至没听说过。我甚至不知道那是什么。
Well, they're so common. You know, they're so common. The states are scary. I'd rather live in my country. You're free here to walk anywhere anywhere and you won't be shot. No one's going to shoot you. A lot of Americans are moving to Australia partly because of this. We're a very different culture.
嗯，它们太常见了。你知道，它们太常见了。美国很可怕。我宁愿住在我的国家。你在那里可以自由地走到任何地方，你不会被枪杀。没人会开枪打你。许多美国人搬到澳大利亚部分是因为这个。我们是一种非常不同的文化。
A lot of people think we're very American, but we are and we aren't. So it's a mixed bag, actually. Anyway, I'm getting hungry. You must be tired. What time is it there for you? It's about 8, 8.30 at night, so I need to get my kids to bed. But I really appreciate your time and just your body of work. It's really nice to meet you and talk to you because, you know,
很多人认为我们非常美国化，但我们是，我们也不是。所以这实际上是一个混合体。无论如何，我饿了。你一定很累了。你那里几点了？大约是晚上8点、8点半，所以我需要让我的孩子们睡觉。但我真的很感激你的时间和你所有的作品。见到你并和你交谈真是太好了，因为，你知道，
I've been reading it since college. So thank you so much. I can't thank you enough. to you because you know i've been reading it since college so um it's thank you so much i can't thank you enough thank you very much and um keep in touch yeah we'll uh we'll talk soon uh take care bye There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我从大学开始就一直在读它。所以非常感谢你。我怎么感谢你都不为过。对你，因为你知道我从大学开始就一直在读它，所以嗯，非常感谢你，我怎么感谢你都不为过。非常感谢你，嗯，保持联系。是的，我们会，我们会很快再谈。嗯，保重，再见。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。